there's one habit that will change your
life and it is do not sleep with your
phone because the one decision everybody
makes that kills your productivity kills
your focus tanks your mental health is
before you get yourself right you grab
your phone and check in with the world
and that means you gave your most
important commodity your time and your
attention to things that don't matter
use a 5-second rule 54321 get out of bed
do not lay there like a human pot roast
marinating in fear staring at the
ceiling get out of bed so people who hit
the snooze button based on the research
when you drift back into sleep it
triggers your brain to go into a sleep
cycle that typically lasts between 75
and 90 minutes and when the alarm goes
back off minutes 5 minutes you're in
what they call a state of sleep inertia
it impacts your productivity for 4 hours
make your bed because it is a way to
keep a small promise to yourself it's
also a way to have a nice place to come
back to like a gift tonight the third
thing I want you to do when you go to
the bathroom is I want I want you to
look in the mirror and I want you to add
an high five in the mirror to your
morning routine we did this massive
study 50% of men and women cannot look
at themselves in the mirror in the
morning and the rest of us glance at
ourselves in the mirror and focus on
what we hate if you physically raise
your hand without saying a word and you
raise your hand to the mirror something
crazy happens a lifetime of positive
neurological programming that has been
attached to the act of giving a high
five to other people gets aimed back at
you the next thing I want you to do is
simply Take 5 minutes the remaining 5
minutes that you have and do some kind
of mindset practice and as the close of
the practice before you look at your
phone I want you to decide what is one
thing that matters to me today that I'm
going to make progress on that's it hey
it's S car Michael and I make these
videos because I need them from me
because I want to wake up every day and
watch a video that puts me in a mindset
to believe in myself more and go off and
accomplish amazing things and attack the
day and I hope that this video does that
for you as well so today let's get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only Mel Robbins
enjoy the high five habit has taught me
how to
truly be fulfilled and be connected to
myself to support myself and that's what
you need right now you can't rely on
anything outside of you you cannot rely
on the world fixing itself you have to
find your power inside you when you know
that you can have your own back and when
you know that you can literally move the
needle on anything through your own
attitude and your own um uh effort you
will have a sense of confidence you've
never experienced before I see Bridget
asked does the high five habit serve as
a reset for our brains yes it does in
fact it does something even more
profound than a reset for your brain
what it does Bridget is and this is a
GameChanger and I'm going to explain the
science right
now it not only hits the reset button
and breaks all of those negative habits
that are in your mind the the negative
selft talk the bashing the Judgment the
shame the all of it it hits the reset
button on that and more
importantly it programs in an entirely
new soundtrack as it Rel reles to how
you see yourself and you want to know
the coolest part everybody you don't
have to say a darn
thing your body and your mind are
designed to do this for you after you
wake up 543 21 and you get up and then I
make my bed you go high five to the
heart you got a calm nervous system now
I want you to walk into the bathroom and
when you walk into the bathroom and you
stand with yourself in front of the
mirror I want you to take a moment okay
and I want you to just be with yourself
because I guarantee you right now you
have a habit that is part of your
morning routine and that habit that you
have that's part of your morning routine
is the opposite of a high five this is
the part of your morning routine you
know where you're brushing your teeth
and you basically check out and you
start to bash your appearance or you
ignore yourself or you think about the
day ahead and you automatically think
about everything that's about to go
wrong or that you haven't done this is
the part of your morning routine is a
habit where your mindset goes negative
and so what I want to do is I want you
to create a brand new deliberate and
intentional habit right after you brush
your teeth because you got to clean
those teeth of yours you know you cannot
go out in the world with dragon breath
every day you got to clean the teeth the
second that you put your toothbrush down
now we are going to do the high five
habit and I want you to do it right
after you brush your teeth because
science tells us when you stack a new
habit with something you already do
every day it makes it much easier for
your brain to remember it and for it to
become part of your subconscious routine
so as you put the toothbrush down and
you stand there I want you to take a
minute and I want you to look at
yourself and look past your body there's
a human being in there a human being
that has been waiting for you to wake up
and look them in the eyes and start
showing up and supporting and cheering
and celebrating them and as you look at
yourself I want you to think about
something who are you going to be today
for that
person how are you going to show up
today for the person you see reflected
in the
mirror and as you think about your life
and what matters to you and what your
goals are what's the game that you're
playing how we going to inch the ball
down the field
today because remember I believe that
productivity is about making progress in
something that matters to you so what is
the game you're playing today that
matters to you and how we going to inch
the ball down the field and once you've
set that intention which based on recent
research
everybody all you need is just a minute
of intentional reflection about how
you're going to show up today and who
you're going to be and based on research
it increases your productivity it
changes how you behave and it increases
the impact that you have on those PE
those folks around you when you catch
yourself procrastinating
forgive
yourself step
one the next time you catch yourself
procrastinating Step One is forgive
yourself and there's a really profound
reason
why procrastination is not about
laziness it's not about a lack of
discipline it's not something you do
because you're dumb procrastination is a
coping mechanism you just have a desire
to feel good right now and you deserve
that you have a desire to lessen the
stress in your life and you deserve to
lessen the stress in your life I get it
and this first step to forgive yourself
this comes from research from Dr pel by
the way he has been studying
procrastination for two decades I mean
just imagine that studying
procrastination for two that that is a
dedicated person right there and we
thank you for your service to all of us
his research found that people who
forgive themselves
are less likely to procrastinate again
in fact there was a study that he did I
want to turn to the page I got the book
right here he co-authored a paper about
how students who forgave themselves for
procrastinating were less likely to
procrastinate on their next test it
sounds silly but part of the problem
that psychologists have uncovered is
that when you're somebody that
procrastinates you're really hard on
yourselves to begin with in fact being
hard on yourself is one of the major
causes of why you're so damn stressed
and so taking a moment and forgiving
yourself and you've got to actually have
a talk with yourself where you are
sitting there like oh my God two hours
just went by wow I must be really
stressed out I forgive myself for just
blowing off two hours on social media
and you know what I can spend the next
hour setting my day up tomorrow for
success or maybe you see all your bills
and you realize you haven't opened those
suckers in two months just go wow I
haven't opened my bills in two months I
must be really nervous about this I
forgive myself for not doing that and
you know what I'm going to do I I'm I'm
G to just do the best that I can I'm G
to face this head on because the next
step that you're going to take once you
forgive yourself you got to recognize
that you're doing
it why because patterns and habits
repeat unless you replace them and so
noticing that it's a pattern catching
yourself forgiving yourself that is a
way we're going to break this pattern
what you're dealing with when you have
impostor syndrome is you're dealing with
a lack of
selfworth you
literally kind of see all the things
working out but you've got this like
annoying voice in your head that's
saying you don't deserve this this is
luck how many of you have that story
this is luck this is going to run out
this isn't due to me yeah we got to
literally destroy that voice that is
from your past
and part of the reason why you have that
Bo that voice by the way is because of
racism it's because of discrimination
it's because of childhood trauma it's
because of uh various experiences that
you've had where either your experience
is growing up or Society at large has
made you feel either overtly or in a
really like gross and sort of Sly way
like you don't belong and so it is
critical for you to start to punch that
voice literally out of your head and I'm
going to give you some steps to do it
okay um the second thing that's really
important is that in addition to
stopping down that voice because it's
not your
voice that is somebody else's voice that
your brain listened to and then started
repeating and the thing about your brain
is that your brain is this really cool
computer that learns
patterns and what I want you to
understand is that patterns
repeat unless you break and replace them
and if you have a pattern of thinking
like what Heidi has that says you're not
worthy you don't deserve this luck is
going to run out at some point that you
know what's going to hit the fan again
brace don't count on anything like you
didn't earn this if you got that pattern
running in your head that is a broken
pattern you're not broken that pattern
of thinking is broken and so the Line in
the Sand that I want to draw starting
today is you're not allowed to listen to
that garbage anymore we are going to go
on a mission together to notice whenever
it comes up oh interesting there it is
there's that pattern it's spinning just
like a load of laundry right up there
and I'm going to teach you once you
recognize that pattern you're going to
use this thing that I created called the
5-sec rule you're going to count
backwards 5 4 3 2 1 because that shuts
that down and counting backwards let's
all do it together here we go 5 4 3 2 1
now notice when you counted did you feel
a little pressure right here yeah that
was me hypnotizing you no I'm just
kidding um what you are feeling is by
counting backwards it's a little brain
hack that interrupts all the garbage
that's here in the interior part of your
brain this is where imposter syndrome
lives everybody this is where anxiety is
this is where self-doubt is this is
where self-criticism is this is where
it's all stored when you notice oh
there's that voice again and you count
backwards 5 4 3 2 1 you shut it down and
then you awaken this part of your brain
this is the part of the brain that you
used when you were taking the SATs this
is the part of the brain that you used
when you applied for that job when you
speak up in that meeting when you tell
somebody no you cannot borrow my dress
tonight no when you have boundaries
right this is the part of the brain that
gives you immediate control over what
you think can do next also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write write down what your key takeaways
are and your specific plan of action to
make sure you're getting results if you
want the worksheet design specifically
for this video absolutely for free
there's a link in the description below
go click on it and start building the
momentum in your life and your business
I'll see you there here's what everybody
gets wrong about
manifesting everybody at least kind of
in the mass Market what you're trained
to think about when you think about
manifesting is vision boards and when
you hear the word vision boards you
think about the big stuff should you
have big dreams of course you should
should you dream of building a mansion
on the ocean if that's your thing yes
should you dream of the Log Cabin yes if
you want a Lamborghini or the new Ford
Broncos should you put yeah yes yes yes
if you want the family if you want the
body should you think about yeah
absolutely here's where everybody goes
WR you dream about the end you make this
gorgeous collage of all this stuff that
has nothing to do with your current
life that literally as you're sitting in
your studio apartment with the cat box
that hasn't been changed in two weeks no
food in the fridge no food in the fridge
and you're looking for a job and you're
staring at a mansion going
someday it's going to make you feel like
a loser because the gap between where
you are and where you want to go it
seems
insurmountable and so what happens based
on the research is when you only
visualize the endgame Lewis it's
demotivating at first it's really fun to
like have a bottle of wine and make your
like collage I'm going visualize I'm
slap this up there's my vision board
this fabulous love attraction baby come
on I'm G think about it it's going to
come to
me okay I've been doing this for two
days I'm not I'm still in this apartment
with the cap box that needs to be
changed the way to visualize properly is
to visualize the bridge between where
you are and and where you need to go the
bridge yes and
particularly the horrible stuff I like
to think about life as one long road
trip every year of your life is a mile
marker on the road of life and the thing
about this road trip is it's a solo
Journey you started at Mile zero and you
were alone that's how you came into this
world and wherever the road of your life
leads you when you leave this world
you're going to be alone when you leave
yes you'll be surrounded by family and
friends but when you actually pass over
you are on your own and the truth is it
is a solo Journey yes you're going to
drive parallel with some people yes
you're going to intersect with some
people yep you're going to travel in
packs but you are driving alone and look
I'm not telling you this to make you
feel isolated or unsupported that's the
last thing that I want you to feel the
reason why I'm telling you this is
because I want you to understand the
power that you have to make these dreams
part of your day-to-day life as you
pursue them I mean maybe you've been so
worried about what everybody else is
going to think and that's what's kept
you from starting your YouTube channel
or writing that screenplay or making a
career change I'm here to tell you no
one gives a about what you do you want
to know why because everybody else is
driving their own car on their own solo
journey and they're busy trying to
figure out their own life when you
realize that the only person who is
truly judging you right now is
you when you Embrace that you're the one
in your way it can spark a fire in your
gut yes it sucks that my friend has been
telling herself for 20 years that she's
not a real writer that she's not a
respected writer that it's not that
interesting yeah that sucks to wake up
and realize that you're the one that's
been dragging yourself down but you want
to know what sucks more spending another
20 years never writing it so step one
you have to acknowledge the thing that's
on your list and that's in your heart
and then step two is take
responsibility for doing whatever you
can however you're capable in whatever
big or small
way to move toward it it's serious about
looking ahead instead of looking back
looking out the window in front of you
at the road ahead and where you want to
go you can inch your way day by day week
by week month by month year by year to
creating a whole new life for yourself
in terms of my own experience with
getting serious about creating the skill
of confidence is it's a GameChanger the
more that you build confidence in your
life the greater the risks you're going
to take and that's critical in business
in life for fulfillment I also have the
ability to say no and not even be
bothered by what other people are going
to feel why because I have the skill of
confidence it also makes you an
incredible negotiator because you
realize you would rather be respected
than be liked and see this kind of need
to be liked or to look good is part of
the reason why you doubt yourself all
the time I want you to bring that power
back internally that's what the skill of
confidence does and you'll also be able
to recognize when you're afraid of
something and that that fear is just
kind of bull in your head and you have a
choice you don't have to let fear stop
you anymore and that's where the skill
of confidence comes in and the same's
going to be true for you so I think it
kind of begs the question if confidence
is something that we all want why is it
so hard to master I'll tell you why
because when it comes to the research
around confidence it is some of the most
dry boring no offense to the confidence
researchers and writers out there but
I'm talking if you have trouble sleeping
just print out a study about confidence
that'll that that'll put you into deep
REM sleep it's also confusing and even
Google isn't much of a help on this
topic if you search how to be confident
you know what the top results one of
them says be true to you what the hell
does that even mean be true to you and
honestly be true to you that is not what
the research says the problem and why
it's hard for people to develop the
skill of confidence is the research has
not been boiled down into tactical
information that you can apply to your
day-to-day life and that's where your
friend Mel Robbins comes in so here's
your first assignment on today's podcast
because you know we're not just
listening here this is a doing podcast
and we're going to make this tactical
and relevant
immediately assignment number one be
selfish as you listen I want you to
listen a particular way I want you to
listen and think what's in it for me and
so let me ask you a question to help you
get really selfish if you had more
confidence like I could go and boom you
have more confidence than you've ever
had in your entire life life how would
your life be different how would your
future be different now Heather has
already shared that she has this awesome
promotion which she clearly earned I
mean businesses don't just give those
out as Charity if a business has
promoted or hired you they believe in
your ability to execute but now she's
freaking out she doesn't have the
confidence now when you think about
confidence how would more conf
confidence help Heather's life be
different well confidence would allow
Heather to step into that role right and
she would be able to lose the self-doubt
and the impostor syndrome and the
panicking and she'd be able to act like
the leader that the organization
promoted her to be right without all the
like nervousness and crap going on in
her head what about you let's get
selfish what would more confidence allow
you to do that you're not currently
doing would you be able to say no no
would you be better with boundaries are
there more risks you would take is there
a conversation you've been avoiding with
yourself or someone else would you be
able to stand up for yourself Advocate
more for yourself ask for what you need
what about work would you be more
visible would you speak up more all of
that that you just envisioned it's all
within your reach my definition of
confidence that I want everyone to walk
away with is confidence is the
willingness to try in research there is
something called The Confidence
competency Loop and what that means is
that as you try something for the first
time like I was curling my hair this
morning and I freaking burned my ear and
my daughter casually says got to learn
somehow by trying and by the way
screwing it up and burning my ear I
still am gaining a little bit of
confidence I know to hold this thing a
little bit further away from my ear now
by gaining confidence by burning my ear
I now am going to try again and I'm
gonna be a little bit better and I'm GNA
gain a little bit more confidence and
then I'm going to try again and I'm
going to learn even more and so
confidence at the heart of confidence is
action it's the willingness to try and
all you need is to know that if you try
you're not going to die you're just
going to learn something and when you
learn something it removes a little bit
of the insecurity so that it makes it
slightly easier to try again and so I
would follow the 60% rule okay and I use
60% because that is the figure that was
in the HP study about men applying for
jobs when they feel 60% qualified MH if
you look at something that you want to
do or try or apply for and you
feel whether it's 60% qualified okay I
got 60% of the stuff because the truth
is a job description everybody a dating
profile that is not requirements that's
a wish list okay if you got 60% of this
stuff freaking go for it that's rule
number one the 60% rule the other thing
is is that if you're looking at doing
something that you're scared to do maybe
it's signing up for an improv class
maybe it is ordering the podcast
equipment maybe it's signing up for
genius like you've been thinking about
it you've been thinking about it you've
thinking about it if you on a scale
you're on this teeter totter if you tip
more toward I'd really like to so about
60% right wait versus 40% I'm kind of
nervous freaking do it that's how you
build confidence because back to the
original thing that we're talking
about self-doubt grows when you engage
in negative talk to talk yourself out of
the things you want to be trying there
is so much pain Jay in talking yourself
out of trying
things and it just makes me so sad and
frustrated to see so many of you that
are listening wasting years of your
life really feeling this desire to try
something and putting all your energy
all your energy into talking yourself
out of it what's the number one thing
that people have come up to you and said
Mel I'm so glad that you told me that CU
I've been applying that in my day-to-day
life it's without a doubt the 5-second
rule which is a brain hack that I
invented 14 years ago when anxiety
consumed me we were 800 Grand in debt
and I couldn't get out of bed so we're
talking about morning routines and
finding space for yourself and I would
literally spend an hour every morning
staring at the ceiling consumed with our
problems and anxiety and depression and
the 5sec rule is a simple tool everybody
needs to know it every kid needs to know
it you simply count backwards 5 4 3 2 1
in a moment where you're hesitating or
afraid and then move just get up oh
absolutely because something happens in
your brain when you count backwards you
interrupt the patterns of worry and
procrastination and beating yourself up
and you go 5 4 3 2 1 and you require the
prefrontal cortex to pay attention which
is the part of the brain that gives you
immediate control over what you do next
we are in too much of a cancel culture
we ghost people we label people and toss
them to the side and I believe that
every human being is capable of changing
and I also believe that if you want
people to become better whether that's
better in terms of their mental health
or better in terms of their habits or
addictions or beliefs or whatever it may
be you have to create room for people to
change and by labeling somebody as toxic
and then just tossing them out the
window
you are not identifying the behavior
that doesn't work for
you and when you start to go the
behavior of s of you giving me the
silent
treatment is toxic
behavior and this is what my boundary is
with it I want you to
know that when you have the
Revelation that the voice that you've
listened to
for
years the voice that's held you back
that made you feel like that it's
actually not even
yours that can make your heart seize for
a minute it's kind of one of those like
wait wait
what and then when I add on top of it
that you're not to
blame for the crap that somebody
programmed into your head you were just
a little person with 3 lbs of macaroni
that was trying to absorb everything
around it and our brains love patterns
and it picks up on patterns of
speaking
and that's what your brain
did and so if you're having this
Revelation
holy I've thought that everything's my
fault for my entire life because
somebody made me believe it was and then
I held on to that
belief don't freak out
this is great news because so many
people spend their entire lives not even
realizing that it's
possible to change the way you think it
is possible to put a new playlist in
your mind it is possible to filter the
world completely differently and to make
your brain work for you now are you
going to have positive thoughts all day
long
no are you going to be like you know
a th% confident
no but can you stop torturing
yourself
yes can you start encouraging yourself
you better believe you can can you
separate what your narcissistic piece of
ex spouse said to you from what you
actually believe about
yourself that you want to believe about
yourself
yeah you can can you do it overnight no
you're going to have to work at this
just like the people in your past worked
over time at saying things to you that
beat you down so my biggest struggle now
is doing creating self- love for myself
without feeling guilty without feeling
like I'm not being humble enough or
without feeling like I'm less of a
mother or less of a wife because I'm
taking care of myself um I know it's the
other way I know that I have to take
care of me so I can take care of others
but I just have a hard time doing it
without feeling that guilt Janet I got
some bad news you can't remove the
guilt I'm GNA say that again when you
first start putting yourself first you
will not remove the guild and so I just
want to be honest about that but let me
give you the two takeaways okay that are
really important because this really
isn't about guilt this is about you
defining for
yourself what it means to be a good wife
and a good mother and a good person in
your eyes and so I'm going to give you
two major wakeup calls that I had around
this topic and then I'm going to tell
you this crazy story so the first wakeup
call that I got is this notion that the
people who love you they will be annoyed
with you when you put yourself first it
is true they are not going to like it
they like you being the person that you
are right now it is convenient for them
that you put them first it is wonderful
the dynamic that's in place but it's no
longer good for you so just expect that
the people who you love will be annoyed
or disappointed or upset when you start
putting yourself first but they're still
going to love you it's not an either or
thing and I'll explain more about that
and second this is a huge wakeup call
what if the guilt doesn't go
away what if guilt is actually a good
thing what if guilt is super healthy to
feel right
now in fact that's what I believe I
believe that the guilt is good I believe
that the guilt is healthy and I believe
that you can reframe it see Guilt shows
that you care that's why you feel that
way if you were a narcissistic douchebag
you wouldn't feel guilty at all for
putting yourself first I want to frame
guilt in a different way for you okay
let's frame it from a Bad Sign O I'm
doing something bad I'm putting myself
first into a good one stop seeing guilt
as a bad thing because you're not doing
anything wrong when you put yourself
first start seeing guilt as a good thing
guilt is a sign that you're breaking
free of this people pleasing habit you
feel guilty because putting yourself
first is just a new feeling that's it
you know I had this Insight a few years
ago that I think might help you two
things can be true in life at the same
time you can put yourself first and
disappoint people and they can still
love you even though they're
disappointed and here's another examp
example of how two things can be true at
the same time you can feel guilty and
you can still put yourself first pretty
cool it's not an either or and that's
why I say that this topic about people
pleasing is about balancing your needs
with the fact that in order to have
great relationships you do have to
compromise sometimes and the balance
comes in because in order for you to
have the life that you want you are
going to disappoint appoint people that
you love sometimes I am here at the
Dallas Convention Center and there are
3,000 chairs out there and we have just
run through the tech rehearsal and I'm
going to tell you a little secret about
um how I manage my uh nerves and how I
flip it into excitement and this is
something you can steal there's always a
reason why you are doing something and
when you can find the reason or purpose
for why you want to either give that
speech or destroy this sales uh
presentation or walk into your boss and
advocate for yourself because of the
contributions that you're making or you
just want to find the courage to stand
up in a town meeting and talk there's
always a reason why and so before you're
about to do it one of the things that
you want to do is you want to remind
yourself of why this matters to you I
want to for example at work I want to be
compensated and valued for my
contributions and it's my responsibility
to make those contributions known and so
I'm going to be super proud of myself if
and when I say this or I want to make a
difference in my town and so I'm going
to have to start speaking up because my
voice needs to be heard I don't want to
be complaining about what's going on in
this town in my own house I want to be
advocating for what changes I'd like to
see make because I can make a difference
for me whenever I give a speech I always
say the same thing to myself I say that
yes there are 3,000 seats here but I'm
only ever talking to one person and I
believe that there is one person in this
audience
today who is here because they are meant
to be here and there is something that I
am about to say that
will change their entire life that
they're going to learn something that
might cure their anxiety or that might
help them through a very very very dark
moment to know that this is temporary
there is someone that's going to be
inspired to make a major change and I
know that in the course of the hour that
I am speaking on this stage something is
going to happen that is meant for that
person and if I trust that it allows me
to just ditch the script and show up as
my full highest Express self you know
look it might be that I trip on the
stage coming out not planned but
somebody in the audience seeing that wow
if that woman on the stage trips and she
gets back up maybe I can stumble and get
back up too look at how she just brushes
it off and she doesn't care what if I
had that I mean it could be that it
could be something really profound like
getting sober or leaving a really
abusive marriage so I remind myself of
that and I'm only ever talking to one
person and that helps me uh it helps me
to stay focused and to know that what
I'm about to do even if it makes my
stomach twist and Knots or even if I'm a
little quote nervous about how it's
going to go it helps me stay aligned
with my purpose and that's where your
power Power Alley is always in life and
that's why it's so important for you to
push yourself to express yourself and
advocate for yourself and share your
story and so steal that
idea remind yourself of why you're doing
this only talk to one person and tell
yourself that there is a person in this
room and you are meant to say something
in this room because somebody needs to
hear you say it and when you trust that
it's not about you it's about the impact
that you're about to make it's okay to
be
comfortable it's not okay to be
small being too small in life telling
yourself that you should be small that
ah it's okay you know
I that's the number one issue shrinking
yourself you see I for the last couple
years every single January I have taught
a course about the science of dreaming
and not just dreaming but dreaming big
and dreaming big as a way to create a
whole new chapter in your life a way to
tap into your potential and more than
200,000 people around the world have
taken this science of dreaming course
with me and here's the number one thing
that I noticed after teaching this
course over and over and over again to
people around the world it's that
telling yourself that you're small
putting a lid on your own dreams on your
own potential convincing yourself that
me is okay that's the biggest problem if
you're somebody who doesn't know what
you you want I guarantee you it's
because you do things that make you feel
small and then you tell yourself that's
okay and here's the thing that I'm
really worried about I'm worried about
the fact that if you continue to do this
if you continue to tell yourself I don't
know what I want I can never have it I'm
46 I tried it's hard it's not going to
work out for me if you are the one that
is against your big dream in
life that is the reason why you're
unhappy that you are the single biggest
loudest voice for why you can't have
what you deserve that is the source of
misery that is the source of feeling
lost and so we got to stop that right
now because the fact is I don't care how
long you've worked on your dreams how
long you've avoided your dreams how long
you've been scared of your dreams how
long long you've downplayed your dreams
those dreams are still very much alive
inside of
you you're not supposed to be small
you're not supposed to be arguing
against your dreams let other people do
that you're the one who's supposed to
have the biggest and the loudest and the
brightest voice when it comes to the
matter of your dreams it's really hard
to find the courage to make a decision
that is the right decision for you and
it's hard because we are so quick to
consider what everybody else is thinking
we're so quick to weigh how our decision
is going to impact somebody else's
feelings that's why we don't trust our
gut we all know we need to trust our gut
that like that's du the thing is how and
so takeaway number one that I want you
to leave with is stop saying trust your
gut and start saying I need to have the
courage to make decisions that are right
for me
second feeling feeling
feeling give yourself the ability and
the time and the the quiet to drop into
your
body and feel whether or not the
decision or the direction opens up
possibility makes you feel like you're
growing and thriving it levels you up it
may be scary as I mean think about Amy's
Story how the hell you going to like do
12 months of Revenue in one month you
have you just declared that who the does
that you
do if it feels like a part of you is
opening up there you go there's your
decision if it feels like a part of you
is shrinking oh I'm going here because
everybody in my family went here I'm a
doctor because everybody in my family is
a doctor I live here because everybody
lives here that's not the right
decision and
finally when you do drop in and you
allow yourself to step onto a tour with
the future you you're going to feel the
no first listen to it you're going to
feel the yes because it feels like an
opening find the courage Alana said in
her opening sentence to me I'm scared of
the rejection I will face when I start
making choices for the new me you know I
read something interesting and I want to
tell you this before I forget it and
then I'm going to talk generally about
friendship hoping that the way that I'm
thinking about friendship will help you
lose the guilt number one um this kind
this came from a book that my husband
was reading about alcohol and it really
what made me stop and think and that is
this when you decide that you don't want
to drink for whatever reason what's
interesting about being somebody that
doesn't drink at a party is that the
only person that gives a what's in your
glass is you nobody else typically cares
but the thing that's interesting is that
when somebody says to you would you like
a drink and you say no I'm not drinking
I'm not drinking for the month of
January or no I'm sober or not you know
I don't feel like it what happens is the
fact that you're turning down the
alcohol it can actually magnify somebody
else's struggle with their own decisions
around it and so the first thing that I
want to point out is if you have friends
that make you wrong for changing your
life for the better that's their issue
it's not yours
and so you got to untangle the fact that
they have baggage about getting in shape
or they have baggage about going to the
bar that's theirs and it has nothing to
do with the decisions that you're making
so if your friends in general give you
blowback for changing for the better
what you need to say in the back of your
mind is interesting they're obviously
very conflicted about their choice to go
to the bar and drink every night but
that has nothing to do with me here's
the other thing you can do if they start
to make you wrong you can say well you
want to go to Planet Fitness with me
instead it doesn't sound like you want
to be at the bar so that said let me
talk to you a little bit about friends
friends are people that you care about
and I have this test I call it the
funeral test if somebody in your life
were to die ask yourself would I go to
their funeral if the answer's yes
they're a friend of yours that's the
test for whether or not in my opinion
someone is a friend because it means you
care about them now here's the other
thing about friendship that I want you
to understand you can care about
somebody and not like hanging out with
them and that's the situation that
you're in right now that you have plenty
of friends that you care about if they
were to die you would go to their
funeral if they needed you you would be
there if you saw them you'd be happy to
see them but you don't like to hang out
with them the other thing that I want
you to think about is that and that's
okay that's like a normal part of
friendship and the reason why that's a
normal part of friendship is because one
of the things that we know about life is
that you're always going to be changing
in the old pattern and the old chapter
you had certain certain patterns right
in the old chapter of your life you
would go to the bar and drink you would
go to the store and spend money you
didn't have you're in a new chapter now
and so you have different patterns when
your life takes on different patterns
whether it's you're no longer going to
the bar you're going to the gym the
pattern might even be that one of your
kids is playing with a different soccer
team or maybe you've moved to a
different street in your town when the
patterns change so will your circle of
friends it's a fact of life but that
doesn't mean your old friends the ones
that you used to drink with aren't
friends anymore it just means that you
don't want to hang out with them you
still care about them but you don't like
doing what they do all anxiety comes
from childhood and it comes from the
experience of being separate in
childhood and so every single one of us
has an experience and you may not
remember it because 80% of your brain is
formed by the time you're 5 years old
but you have an experience where you as
a kid feel
distinct and separate from your
caregiver and he talks a lot about this
concept of a parental mismatch so there
are a lot of us that have parents who
are wonderful people or maybe they're
not wonderful people but you have
parents who are wonderful people but for
you emotionally just like the five love
languages there can be a mismatch in
terms of the love language you speak in
need and what your partner does that
your parent and the way that they
provide emotional support is a mismatch
and so as a kid when you don't get the
reassurance you need or when you don't
feel loved or seen or heard or accepted
you feel separate from the parent that
you're biologically hardwired and
needing to bond with which also means
you feel unsafe and so as a little kid
at some point an alarm would go off in
your body whenever you felt separate
from your parents and it could be as
innocuous as go hug your uncle and
you're like this I don't want to hug my
uncle like get in there um or don't do
that now I'm busy or the snapping at you
and you immediately feel that alarm
because you feel separate and so what
happens is that this alarm that starts
going off and going off and going off in
moments where you feel separate you're
not feeling the love that you need
you're not feeling connected you're not
feeling reassured it starts to go off
all the time now as you get older and
older and older I mean we've all had the
experience of walking into see old
friends at lunch and for many of us we
feel that alarm go off they've all
arrived there they're all talking you
feel that sense of Separation that's
anxiety that's what it is it's in your
body and it is according to Dr Kennedy
it is the little you basically waving
their hand saying I need a little
reassurance right now that's all that it
is and for decades I have approached
what has been an experience of living
with anxiety from the neck up I mean the
5sec rule is a neck up approach and
based on the last two years of intense
therapy that I've been in and you know a
lot of stuff that I've recently learned
from Dr Kennedy I realize it is
fundamentally a neck down issue that
attacking anxiety and these moments
where you feel separate or scared or you
feel the alarm AR go off in your body if
you instead of treating it like a signal
that something's wrong if you actually
treat it as a signal that you just need
a little bit of love from yourself right
now just put your hand on your heart you
can like take a towel and kind of do
this on your back rub it back and forth
and you feel like you're hugging
yourself take a deep breath tell
yourself whatever you need to hear in
that moment in order to reassure
yourself that you're going to be okay or
that whatever you know like get it you
know you feel a little nervous but all
those people at that table love you it's
freaking
Bonkers how powerful of approaches and
it's also made me realize that
wow I am so not used to giving myself
that kind of love and reassurance no
wonder I'm uncomfortable letting other
people give it to me when you stand
before yourself in front of a
mirror and you look at
yourself you drag with you your entire
past standing between you and the person
you see reflected is everything that's
been done to
you it's all of the abuse and the trauma
and the mistakes and the disappointment
and the
hardic and so many of you take all the
stuff the bad stuff that's happened to
you or in your life and you use that as
evidence to say I'm a failure I'm not
worthy I don't deserve it see all this
evidence that person I see is not
somebody who deserves a high five
because of what's happened to them or
maybe like the rest of us you've done
things in your past that you deeply
regret you were doing things because you
were trying to survive and you haven't
forgiven yourself and so you stand there
every morning and subconsciously what's
there is is is
judgment and so if you're resis
raising your hand and celebrating
yourself just for standing there and
just for being there and just for
showing up for another day despite all
this stuff that's
happening the resistance is the
problem because until you forgive
yourself until you start to look
yourself in the eye and say because of
all this stuff I deserve a high five
I've survived this because of everything
that has happened to me and because I
still show up and try a little harder I
deserve support I deserve celebration
and I need it I need
it it's so obvious and yet none of us do
this we stand in judgment you think
because you got fired or your last
business failed you are a failure and
that's why you won't cheer for yourself
right now if you have big goals you
better stand in front of that mirror and
high-five yourself every day every
single step of the way stop looking
around and waiting for everybody else to
do it start giving it to yourself and
you'll be shocked at how much more
quickly things start to happen at how
much more joy you experience along the
way at how much more present you are
yeah it's wild and this isn't about like
pumping yourself up to think you're like
the best person on the planet this is
like the
Baseline this is literally being like
you know what you're going to have an
okay day let's go do this you know what
I see see you I know this is hard keep
going I I know you're nervous to have
this hard conversation with this person
I believe you can do it yeah let's go
yeah like it's just one little boost
along the way you know if you think
about the things that go
viral it's little kids in front of a
mirror with their parents getting them
to talk themselves yeah
correct we all know that's how we're
supposed to feel mhm but we feel weird
and cheesy practicing it you kidding me
right the other thing that goes viral
all these teachers that are high-fiving
and fist bumping kids with it handshakes
as they go in and the mirror one with
the I am that just kind of went viral
why do we all love that because we know
each one of those kids just felt seen
and felt good and felt motivated walking
into that classroom mhm start your day
that way every single day when you wake
up you can find five minutes or 10
minutes or 15 minutes to move from
thinking about what you want to taking
action on what you want picking up the
pen writing a sentence sending an email
doing the research taking a class all of
these actions are how you move towards
what you want while you're still in the
life that you have that's how you do it
and the other thing that you're going to
have to pay attention to is energy
because just like you are wasting
precious time on that doesn't really
matter to you you are also wasting your
precious energy spending time with
people who are draining it from you who
are not giving it back to you and so
every single day when you wake up I want
you to pay attention to where you're
putting your time and where you're
putting your energy and I want you to
find five measly minutes to start
working on what you want in the physical
world instead of keeping it a secret in
your heart and in your mind one of the
high five habits is what I call giving
your heart a high five
and this in many ways I think is just as
profound as high-fiving your reflection
and just the depth of research that goes
into explaining why it has such a
profound impact in terms of how you
relate to yourself but high-fiving your
heart is putting your hands kind of
right on your heart one on top of the
other CH of the other and saying I'm
okay I'm safe I'm loved and I started
doing this uh when the pandemic hit and
I started wake up to a wave of
anxiety and one of the things that we
learned in writing this book is that the
first thing that you need to be able to
do before your brain can even engage in
new patterns of thinking is to settle
your nervous system so you know we wrote
a bunch about the Vegas nerve but when
you put your hands over your heart first
thing in the morning and give your heart
a high five and say I'm okay okay I'm
safe I'm loved first of all it's true
because if you can say those words
you're okay you're safe you're loved but
secondly it tones What's called the
Vegas nerve which I know you talk about
on the show that that is the secret to
switching between your parasympathetic
and your sympathetic nervous system so
if you're somebody like me who has lived
your life on edge if you grew up in a
cha chaotic household if you've
experienced trauma if you constantly
feel like you're waiting for the other
shoe to drop if you wake up and the
first thought is I've done something
wrong someone's mad at me I want you to
try this other high- five habit by
high-fiving your heart you can say it 15
times if you have to I'm okay I'm safe
I'm loved it will soothe your nervous
system and settle it because you cannot
have new thoughts or learn new Behavior
if your nervous system is on edge or on
hyper alert you're the kind of person
just like me me that every single year
you write down the things that you want
in your life and I would imagine that as
each year rolls on and the new list gets
written you move the thing that you
didn't work on this year to the list
that you do for the next year and on and
on and on I mean how many years have you
been thinking about writing a book or
changing your job or changing where you
live or healing some aspect of your past
or finding love or learning how to love
yourself or St in that business these
things that you hold in your heart they
are meant to be out in the world and
today I'm on a mission to get you to
stop waiting stop waiting for the
perfect time stop waiting to feel ready
stop waiting for the money stop waiting
for permission stop waiting to feel like
somebody's going to care about this the
only person that needs to care enough is
you because today is the day that you're
going to pick up the pen you're going to
start the research you're going to
commit to taking action
why because that's what you're meant to
do with your life you're meant to create
a bigger vision for yourself there was a
research study done about NBA teams so
we got sports fans here check this out
so NBA
teams they did this study where they
wanted to know are there any like
patterns that you could trace back if
you took the championship themes and
then Trace back all the way back to the
preseason are there defined patterns
that are consistent with the
championship teams that are not present
with the teams that perform the worst
and sure enough There Were You can
predict who is going to be in the
Championships rounds of the NBA by a
simple pattern in the preseason and you
want to know what it is the teams that
go on to win have the most number of
high fives backpacks
fist bumps and gestures of
encouragement in the
preseason why would that make a
difference I'll tell you why it makes a
difference because those high fives just
like you highfive a runner every step of
a marathon to encourage them to move
forward they build trust they transfer
energy they say I believe in you they
build partnership and I'm here to tell
you life is
hard you need to build a partnership
with yourself when you stand with
yourself every single morning with a
calm and cool nervous system grounded in
your body and you look at yourself in
the mirror with compassion and
forgiveness and love and understanding
and support and you decide what game
you're going to play today and who
you're going to be and how you're going
to show up and you raise your hand and
you seal that with encouragement support
and
celebration you will be
unstoppable because you will know the
secret to life and that is never giving
up on the person who is staring back at
you in the mirror
and making sure that no matter what
happens the one person who's back you've
always got is the one that's always
going to be with you and you've got an
opportunity every single morning to
start your day by taking care of that
person instead of criticizing and
ignoring them and if you're serious
about changing your life if you're
serious about feeling more fulfilled if
you're serious about enjoying your life
and being content and
feeling like you're in control no matter
what going to happen that you have the
ability to survive this you have the
ability to grow for this you have the
ability to take this opportunity and
make it something even bigger everybody
that struggles with addiction does this
exact same thing tomorrow I'm not
drinking that's it I I'm done with this
and then the next morning it's the
same pattern of negative crap that
you're doing to yourself and this is
exactly what you talk about all the time
it's not the what you need to do it's
how how do you make yourself do the
things that feel hard or scary or or
don't seem like they're going to work
cuz you're resigned and you're stuck in
your patterns that was me I knew I
needed to get out of bed I knew I needed
to stop drinking I knew I needed to look
for a job I knew this wasn't Chris's
fault and I needed to stop screaming at
him all the time but I wasn't doing any
of those things I didn't know how and so
this was the moment I created the 5sec
roll and again this is another I beam or
t beam or whatever the hell beam it's
called I'm sitting in front of the
television and I am watching TV the kids
are in bed and I'm drinking uh Bourbon
and I'm probably on like my fourth
Manhattan and I'm having my nightly pep
talk and I'm going that's it tomorrow
morning it's the new me I I got to wake
up I got to do this I got to do the
other thing and all of a sudden Rich
honest to goodness I see a rocket ship
launch at the end of a commercial and I
go that's it tomorrow morning I'm
launching myself out of bed like a
rocket and that was the beginning of the
5-second rule intermittent fasting is a
health protocol where whereby you focus
on periods of time where you're eating
and periods of time where you are not
eating the purpose of intermittent
fasting is to use periods of time where
you are not eating to help you switch
between the two different energy sources
in your body we learned all about this
in part one from Dr Mindy you have an
energy source that is all all about
sugar and calories and energy that
happens when you eat and then you have a
second energy source that only turns on
after an eight hour period of not eating
anything and Dr Mindy calls that your
fat burning energy source and so what we
learned is that you are designed to
switch between these two cycles kind of
like how you have cycles of sleeping and
cycles of being awake you have a
circadium rhythm cycle cycle if you're a
woman you have a menstrual cycle the
human body runs on cycles and rhythms
and you're eating is no different and
fasting is a way for you to be very
intentional not about what you eat and
that's why this is not a diet diets
focus on what you eat fasting is a
protocol that focuses on when you're
eating for maximum health benefit I
literally fail
over and over and over again I lose my
way a million times before I find myself
and even when I find myself I eventually
feel lost again and go looking for
myself again constantly seeking
constantly growing constantly failing
and so I start this life coaching
business I love it it goes incredibly
incredibly well um this would have been
like 2002 to like 200 I don't know I'm
guessing here six maybe MH and um what
ends up happening is a friend of mine
emails me forwards an email to me and
when you look at the chain of the form
the form when you look at the chain of
the forward what you see at the bottom
is there's somebody at Inc magazine
looking to write an article about life
coaches and I immediately scan the thing
and it's a month old the deadline is
passed I have none of the credentials
they're looking for I have none of the
types of clients they're looking
for
and
I start to go like we always do down the
list of reasons why I should not respond
like we're always arguing against
ourselves always holding ourselves back
and I'm I immediately say wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute um what
would somebody who's more successful
than me do I'm like they apply right so
I take a sip of wine I start typing like
crazy and I just free form this
hilarious response back a month late
with none other credentials da da d d d
da she writes back the next day and says
I was about to turn the article in what
if I come to Boston next week and T
Trail you wow so she comes she follows
me around for a day she ends up
publishing an article and I'm like oh
yes cuz oh that's right cu the article
uh released in 2005 and I'm like this is
going to be amazing the timing of this
article is fabulous this article is
going to print rich and I am going to
have an avalanche of clients it's going
to be awesome the article print
crickets not a single client not a
single inbound email not a nothing
nothing so uh I forget about it I'm out
to dinner one night my phone's ringing
it's a New York number like who the heck
is calling me from New York I pick up
the phone and is this Mel Robbins yeah
this is Mel Robbins hey this is Mary
Duffy from CNBC Mike oh hi Mary Duffy
how are you having no idea who she is
she's like well I saw the article in Inc
magazine and we'd like to fly you down
and talk to you so literally a week
later I find myself on a plane down to
New York drive over to New Jersey walk
into the offices I sit down and I am in
a meeting with the executives at CF
CNBC and they're in a development
meeting oh my God coaching is hot we
think you're amazing we want to do a
show we want to stick it between Kramer
and Donnie deuts was on at the time the
big idea and we'd like you to do D D D D
D walk out of there with a freaking
development deal oh my god let's detour
into the lane of
anxiety of patterns and Trauma uhhuh and
talk about why people self sabotage yes
people don't self sabotage
intentionally nobody wakes up in the
morning and says today I'm going to
screw up my life right that's what I'm
going to do I'm going to drink myself on
the ground I'm going to cheat on my wife
I'm going to embezzle for my company I'm
going to lie to everybody about how I'm
actually feeling I'm going to stop
taking my meds I'm going to kick the dog
like nobody does
that what happens is people get
triggered and they react and then they
fall into Old patterns mhm and so what
happens I believe in
relationships in particular or jobs
where you're like this time it's going
to be different is it's different for
the first 3 to 6 months when it's novel
and when you're intentional and when
everything counts but then when you got
to face
yourself then when it becomes like part
of your life you get lazy and you slip
into Old patterns or when the stakes get
really high let's say you're somebody
who had a parent die early or your dad
abandoned the family and you're scared
to love somebody and so you fall deeply
for somebody and then what gets
triggered is this tremendous fear that
they're going to leave yeah because
that's your lived experience and if you
go back to what you did as a child to
cope with that fear that somebody's
going to leave that's the exact pattern
that you will repeat as an adult mm the
only way to end this or to try to get
your arms around it is to attack it
holistically because so much of this
happens at the subconscious level and it
also it gets triggered first by your
nervous system you're not even aware of
it what are you dealing with just trying
to be there for my husband for my kids
and other people and you're not there
for you
though so is it more overwhelming the
way that you think or overwhelming
because you have so much going on and
you just physically can't get to all of
it physically can't get to all of it
okay one thing that I want you to do and
this is going to sound really
stupid but do you sleep with your phone
yes I do I you just have it right by
me I want you to stop doing that okay
okay and here's why your phone is
distracting you from the things that are
important and your what's on your phone
the number of emails the text people are
sending you the news that's really scary
if you have that sucker next to your bed
do you wake up in the morning and then
lie in bed and look at it it's using my
first thing like thank you Lord I'm
awake and in the phone and then the
phone and when you lay there and you
look at what's on the phone how does it
make you feel emotionally tired before I
get out of the bed yes and does it start
to make you feel overwhelmed about
everything you need to do yes okay what
I want you to do instead is I want you
to put the phone like in your closet or
in your kitchen or in your bathroom plug
it in leave the ringer on cuz if your
kids need to reach you they can call you
not going to text you tell work if you
need to reach me at 2:00 in the morning
don't send me an email don't send me a
text call me okay and then I want you to
go to bed I want you to wake up you're
going to thank the Lord that you woke up
you're going to think about one thing
that you're really grateful for to
settle yourself okay and then you're
going to get up okay you're going to get
up and then I want you to go out in your
kitchen before the madness happens with
the kids in school and it's back to
school and it's overwhelming isn't it
and I want you to take 5 minutes that's
it
five minutes to just sit and think about
what you need for you today just one
thing okay just one thing are you going
to call your mother today are you going
to um read a book for 20 minutes today
are you going to go for a walk at lunch
today what's one thing you're going to
do for you and then let the rest of the
day unfold you can then look at your
phone and get overwhelmed but I want you
to at least start a tiny little
self-care okay practice in the morning
okay if you like to pray when you get
out of bed don't pray in bed you can
thank God for the fact that you got up
but get out of bed okay go into the
kitchen do your morning prayers think
about one thing for you then let the
rest of the world in okay okay I want
you to just crack open crack open a
little bit for you and then it'll start
to expand you can make it 10 minutes you
can make it 15 minutes but if you win
the battle in the morning so that you
can get out of Deb bed without feeling
tired and overwhelmed
can start to spre that through the rest
of your day worrying is wasting time
it's robbing you of what you want to do
in your life and it's making you suffer
in a needless way look I don't want you
to get to the end of your life and look
back and think I wish I hadn't wasted so
much of my precious life on stuff that
didn't matter I wish I didn't let all
that stupid worrying keep me from doing
the things that I always dreamt about
doing
I'm here to tell you that you can learn
how to switch your thoughts to something
more productive and optimistic this is
great news worry is a hackable thing and
I'm going to use a ton of Science and
proven experience to show you just how
to hack it using one magical tool and
here's the great news once you learn how
worry starts you can use that knowledge
to make it stop you can practice this
magical tool every day to quiet mind I
mean just imagine that a quiet
mind wow I know exactly how you feel I
mean I know how exhausting and
frustrating it is to constantly be
trapped in the grinding cycle of
worrying about everything how do I know
this I lived it I've always been worried
I mean if you could be a baby that
worries that was me I'm sure at 11
months when my mom was running late to
heat up my pureed carrots and potatoes I
was probably thinking is she coming back
where is she I'm starving I mean I might
just starve to death here I think she
hates me she's left she maybe she's
angry about the face I made as I tried
the pued snow peas for lunch oh my gosh
what do I do uh I I have to find a new
family to feed me how am I going to find
my new family I got no connections no
money I'm wearing a diaper I can't even
walk yet I'm going to starve to death in
the next 24 hours that was baby mail and
that was just the beginning I mean I was
just kind of warming up for a life of
worry on a very elite professional level
you know as a little kid I worried about
everything from the teacher's reaction
to whether or not the kid in the stall
next to me was going to hear me fart
when I got to Middle School it was all
about whether or not my tough skin jeans
were cool or my acne or my new perm that
I immediately regretted when I was in
college I was worried if I studied
enough for the test if I was going to
flunk out if I was going to go blind
from the grain alcohol I drank from the
garbage can at that frat party I worried
if I had enough gas in the car to get to
the grocery store the truth about
worrying is once you let it start to
spin it just spins out of control I'm
sure you know this I mean worry has
tormented me since I was a kid it
tormented me as a teen in my 20s my 30s
hell my 40s and if I can go from having
this worry as my torturous default and
learn how to interrupt it and redirect
it and program a positive mind you can
too the second you catch yourself woring
when you feel your mind spin when you
feel your shoulders pinch up towards
your ears like new earrings and you feel
your jaw clench and wait there's more
you feel yourself starting to get heavy
and paralyzed and defeated and those
worries start to spin in your mind
here's exactly what you're going to do
it's just six magical words it
encapsulates
incredible research it's so simple you
can do it and don't worry it's going to
work here are the six magical words
you're going to say to yourself every
time you worry what if it all works
out that's
it what if it all works
out look I know what you're thinking you
feel that down right now that's because
you're worried it's not going to work
but what if it all works out what if
these simple stupid six words actually
work what if trying this works out you
just heard me say the words what if it
all works out and you know what your
response was well I don't think it's
going to work out that's why I'm
worrying you got to trust me on this
your worries sound just as dumb as this
magical tool does you have just listened
to your worry for so long that you
believe it part of the reason why
overwhelm is so debilitating is because
when you're overwhelmed your FOC focus
is scattered across absolutely
everything and you're thinking about
your family and your health and the news
and the this and the that and the
presentation and the emails you didn't
do and D D D D D D D D D D and at the
end of the day each and every one of
those things is not really that
important there's probably can we agree
one two or three things a day that
really matter that really need your
attention and the reason why we get so
freaking over overwhelmed with life is
we allow our attention to get scattered
and to get pulled in a bazillion
different
directions and the
solution to feeling more in control and
to literally dealing with overwhelm
which is just an overwhelming amount of
things that really most of which are not
that all important to you but they're
just distracting you which then pulls
your attention away from what really
matters you see I'd rather have you do
two or three things a day day that
really matter to you and let the rest
just kind of fall where they fall right
and so the surprisingly simple way to
deal with overwhelm is to pick one thing
that you're going to focus on every day
for you like no matter what you're going
to do this thing you're going to add a
little structure you're going to add
something that you're committing to as a
way to laser your focus on something
that's in your control it's absolutely
awesome how this works so I'm going to
give you an example when my husband
first got diagnosed with depression he
became very
overwhelmed and what I noticed is that
he decided to take this online fitness
challenge that's a little bit more than
I'm telling you that you should do but
he did this Fitness mental toughness
challenge told 75 hard and even though
it was a pain and even though it was
hard having this challenge to focus on
as something he had chosen that he was
going to commit to every day gave his
life a simple structure that had a lot
of things that were distracting him fall
to the Wayside same thing happened with
our daughter she became very overwhelmed
after she graduated from college did not
know what she wanted to do she was in a
really unhealthy place and committing to
a simple set of new healthy habits that
really were things she could control and
committing to doing it for 3 months it
gave her this real discipline around
focusing on what mattered to her and the
overwhelm started to disappear because
when you create a simple structure for
yourself and you say you know what I'm
going to do this week no matter what
this week I'm just going to get up when
the alarm rings and I am going to move
my body for 30 minutes and that is the
simple structure I am going to put in
place for me and the reason why simple
structures like this are so important is
because in a sea of this which is what
overwhelm is like all this stuff you're
like nope there is one thing that I am
going to do for myself today and that is
the thing that I am going to focus on in
life to make people feel welcome super
important to invite people especially
other women to have a seat at the table
and one of the things that I've learned
and that I'm going to catch you all up
on where we're at okay one of the things
I've learned is that you know it's
there's so much success to go
around have you wrapped your brain
around the fact that there are what 8
billion people on this planet there is
so much success to go around there's so
much
happiness there's a tremendous amount of
money to make there's a ton of people to
date and when you focus on the fact that
there is Limitless possibilities for you
you're not in competition with anybody
in this
room and the louder you cheer for other
people the more you invite people
in the more you will be invited in and
the more cheering there will be for
you it is incredible when you can flip
your mind from being jealous and
competitive and small-minded like if
she's getting that it means I don't oh
no no no no no if you see somebody
getting something that you want it's
evidence you can have it too you're just
going to get it and have it in your own
way and so you want to make it a habit
to cheer for and celebrate all the all
the women everybody you see around you
because their success means you can have
it too and trust me if you are a
talented hardworking kind
person a company will make room for you
they will find another job doing that
same thing and so you focus on you you
you focus on being the best you and I
promise you all the other people around
you that are having those things that
you want that's evidence you can have it
too I like to think of other people as a
light on the path I'm walking down
they're shining a light that helps me
walk in the direction of what I want
what has been profound in my marriage is
that at the heart of all mental health
issues for me at the heart of all your
interpersonal issues with anybody else
is your own
inability to handle uncomfortable
feelings that's it that's it and
I have the just disgusting and awful
toxic behavior of
expelling my uncomfortable emotions at
people mhm and my my inability to
tolerate stress or disappointment or
frustration or expectations not being
met or hurt feelings that creates this
sort of disruption in my body and all of
this stuff it over over the years like I
would expel it at people i' I'd have a
terrible tone of voice I would blame it
on my anxiety and I didn't know any
better cuz I didn't understand that
healing actually doesn't start up here
it actually starts in your body and your
ability to not only tolerate emotions
but to regulate the way that you feel
when you experience emotion and my
husband has the opposite way he
withdraws when he feels painful things
in his body he withdraws and so the
thing that has changed everything for me
Lewis is truly
realizing that you know I the second I
started to dig out all the uncomfortable
feelings and the that had happened or
anything else and I learned how to sit
with it mhm I learned how to give myself
the assurance and the love that maybe I
didn't get as a kid that I didn't
experience other relationships that I
wasn't experiencing that moment learning
how to do that for myself learning how
to regulate my nervous system how to
tolerate the awful stuff that happens to
all of us in
life that has been the biggest change
gameer my relationship I don't get angry
at Chris I completely understand what
you mean when you say it's really hard
to accept a compliment it's hard to
accept a gift you'd rather have it be
about somebody else one of the biggest
breakthroughs I've had in the last
couple years rich is this Epiphany about
my inability to receive love MH and the
fact that I was uncomfortable for a long
time time hearing a compliment or having
somebody say something nice or having a
birthday party thrown for me or
receiving a gift and I have recently had
this breakthrough because I have learned
that there is a extremely tight
connection between feeling anxious and
not allowing love to come in and so I
have this visual rich and I'm going to
explain this to you
because um I just had this emotional
experience happen when you sort of were
like pushing away the love I was trying
to to to to shower you with
so I think when you block love like
imagine like there's this closed door
and when somebody tries to link with you
or connect with you or
authentically tell you how amazing you
are if you have a hard time hearing it
you basically have put a solid door
between you and the other person
and I've been working recently with
visualizing The Galley doors in a
kitchen That Swing both ways because
you're very good at giving love you're
very good at giving support you're are
an incredibly amazing friend because
you're always there when somebody needs
you and you always open the door to
listen to advise to share and I'm the
same way too and for a long time when
somebody would try to give it back to me
the door was closed if you've been
following me for a long time you've
probably heard me talk about the fact
that you should never never never never
hit the snooze button okay and let me
explain why here's how I want you to
wake up when the alarm rings get out of
bed period you want to be a happy person
you want to have a positive mindset you
want to take control of the anxiety the
depression and the stress that you have
do not allow yourself number one when
that alarm goes off to turn it off and
lie in bed and start to ruminate in your
mind about everything that you've got to
do today and how stressed you feel and
to marinate in those negative thoughts I
do not want you to do that you're going
to use the 5sec Rule 5 4 3 2 1 and
you're going to get out of bed the other
thing I do not want you to do is I do
not want you like I used to do I do not
want you when the alarm goes off to
reach over and tap the snooze button the
reason why I do not want you to ever tap
the snooze button is because of how
snoozing for a couple minutes impacts
your neurology it impacts your brain
function again this isn't something I
made up this is wellestablished research
you see I used to be a chronic snooze
button hitter when Chris and I were
going through a really rough time or I
notice in times in my life where I'm
feeling stressed out or overwhelmed when
that alarm goes off there's a small
hesitation where I start to feel a
little stressed and overwhelmed when I
think about the day ahead and it just
feels so safe and so satisfying and and
and and and and so tempting to reach
over and hit the snooze button and doze
off for 9 minutes or 15 minutes and then
the alarm goes off again and then I
reach over and hit the snooze button
doze off for f 9 to 15 minutes and then
the alarm goes off again and then I
reach over and the reason why it's
tempting to do that is because you're
delaying having to deal with your life
you are giving yourself a false sense of
control that I can find 9 to 15 minutes
to just avoid having to deal with what I
want to deal with and so I don't want
you to do that and the reason why I
don't want you to ever hit the snooze
button is because of how dozing off for
9 to 15 minutes impacts the way that
your brain works the way that sleep
works is we fall asleep we sleep in
cycles of about 75 to 90 minutes and
then we start another one and we go into
another sleep cycle for 75 to 90 minutes
and then we typically start another one
and we start another sleep cycle that
goes 75 to 90 minutes and after two or
three sleep cycles or Heck if you're
lucky four of them your body and brain
go into a mode where for about two hours
your brain just goes into a state where
it's getting ready to wake up so for
those of you that wake up naturally
before an alarm goes off or the alarm
goes off and you've had anywhere from 6
hours plus of sleep your mind is now in
a state it's not in a sleep cycle where
it is ready to wake up it is ready to
start the day it is ready to be
deliberate if you wake up in that state
and then you reach over and hit the
snooze button and you doze off for 9 to
15 minutes what do you suppose
your brain starts
again if you're thinking a sleep cycle
you'd be absolutely right and how long
does a sleep cycle last a sleep cycle
lasts 75 to 90 minutes so you drift off
into a sleep cycle your brain does which
lasts 75 to 90 minutes all of a sudden
the alarm goes off 9 to 15 minutes later
your brain is in a sleep cycle you are
in a medical neurological state right
now that scientists call Sleep inertia
it means that by falling into a sleep
cycle and waking yourself up 9 to 15
minutes in it the cortic region of your
brain is now trapped in a sleep cycle
and do you realize it takes your brain
once you're awake four hours to shake
itself loose of the state of sleep
inertia why is sleep inertia a Bad Thing
studies prove that when you're in a
state of sleep inertia it impacts your
speed of processing it impacts your
ability to focus it impacts your ability
to do any kind of strategic thinking so
for you if you're a chronic snoozer like
I used to be and you sleep and then the
alarm goes off then you hit snooze then
you drift into a sleep cycle then the
you drip into a sleep cycle and then the
alarm goes off and you get up your brain
you know how you say when you're a
snoozer you're always like I didn't get
any sleep and you feel so groggy and
tired and you keep saying I didn't get
enough sleep last night I didn't get
enough sleep last night guess what has
nothing to do with how much sleep you
got it has to do with the fact that when
the alarm went off instead of getting up
you started another sleep cycle and then
when the alarm went off 15 minutes later
you woke yourself up and now your brain
is trapped in a sleep cycle you're in a
state of sleep inertia work on your
own because the secret to a happy
relationship
ship is you being happy mhm and the
person that you're with being a happy
person that's like like somebody once
said to me you want to know the secret
to a happy marriage Mel I said what is
it he said marry somebody who's happy
working on your own happiness because if
you're not a happy
person the easiest person to attack is
your intimate partner it's the person
you love the most correct like think
about when you're a kid you have to hold
your together at school you have to like
look good for your friends you have to
like stick it out at that job that you
had as a teenager that you couldn't
stand but when you come home you can you
snap at your mom you might be rude to
your dad you ignore your brothers and
sisters you let it all hang out with
them and we do that with our intimate
partners and so if you're not taking
care of your own happiness you're going
to vomit your baggage at the person who
loves you most so that's it when you
place a bet on life and you place a bet
on yourself to face something to believe
that it's all going to work out that
you're going to figure it out magical
things happen magical things and I'm
telling you there is energy there's an
aliveness inside of you a vibrancy that
will come when you are willing to push
through your fears I know my son wants
to go skydiving for his 18th birthday I
made him a promise I'd do with them it
is my biggest fear other than being
buried alive but um I I do not want to
do it I'm starting to feel a little bit
of vomit in the back of my throat and a
nervous stomach just even thinking about
it but I'm going to do it because I also
want to reach and experience the full
potential of my life and I know every
time that fear holds me back from
reaching out to somebody from
saying it I'm going to go try that thing
to raising my hand when I'm nervous
about how people are going to respond to
jumping into something that I know
nothing
about I'm limiting myself and you're
doing the same thing your mindset and
having a powerful mindset and being
deliberate about what you're going to
think about and what you're not going to
think about it begins the moment you
wake up and believe it or not how you
wake up not when but how you wake up and
the first few things that you do in the
morning will dictate your mood for the
rest of the day which based on science
is going to impact your productivity and
it's going to impact how you feel about
your life and it will also
impact your mindset for the rest of the
day you can think about your morning
routine and whether or not you even have
one in the exact same way that we think
about the brain you're either defaulting
to something that you you always done
that may not no longer serve you or
you're getting deliberate and choosing
to do something that's more positive and
Powerful because you deserve it and that
starts with your morning routine so if
you're the kind of person where the
alarm goes off and you hit the snooze
and then the alarm goes off again and
you hit the snooze and you know
eventually you roll out of bed and you
step into your day and you maybe drink a
big dark cup of coffee and you skip
breakfast and you skip exercise and
you're tired if that's how you start
your
day your mindset is going to be impacted
by that if your alarm goes off and you
immediately reach for your phone and you
start scrolling through Instagram while
you're in bed and looking at Facebook
and you are putting all kinds of stuff
in your brain that triggers fomo that
triggers insecurity that triggers
anxiety that is going to impact your
mindset for the rest of the day and so
starting tonight I want you to take
control and be more deliberate about
your habits in the morning use the alarm
on your phone seriously this is this is
a genius hack put the alarm on your
phone to use to help you be your future
self it's like a it's like a reminder
from the Future Okay cake stun get up go
check on it no seriously so every single
smartphone has the ability to set an
alarm and on the alarm when you go to
set the time there's a there's a
label right now it says alarm you can
literally change the label to help you
remember anything and here's what's
super cool about a simple alarm in your
phone research has found that twice as
many people who received quit smoking
messages quit smoking over a six-month
period so these little systems like
setting an alarm in your phone whether
you're reminding yourself to take the
vitamins that you want to be taking or
you're reminding yourself to get outside
for the run or you're reminding yourself
to spend 30 minutes working on a project
that you wanted to get done they're
going to make you based on the research
twice as successful twice more likely
this simple stuff works and it's not
that hard let's I it's not that hard
right not that hard to put a Post-It
note on the mirror not that hard to set
an alarm in your phone not that hard to
set the water bottle out but you got to
do it okay simple systems work because
your life is complicated enough and if
you can put that posit note up you are
setting yourself up for Success I'm
telling you it's true we spend so much
time twisting ourselves in knots about
unimportant
things and we just talked about how
hideous I'll use the word hideous cuz I
literally looked hi hideous I mean I not
only had a tomato red face and like
crazy witch hair and uh foggy glasses
and bad breath and impacted sinuses and
probably throwing in a camel toe in
there too I didn't have anything tied
around my
waist
um but not giving a [__] about that is
very liberating because otherwise I'd be
embarrassed by my own existence walking
down the sidewalk and I would twist
myself in knots worrying about what do I
look like and how right is my face is my
face coming down and maybe I should go
back to the hotel and take a shower and
get this makeup off my face and blow my
nose before I get a cup of coffee and
and all of that energy twisting myself
around what other people may be thinking
rather than just being okay not giving a
it's so liberating at a very young
age I started to realize and I think you
know we all have this Epiphany where we
go oh holy cow
when I get good grades my parents like
me and they love me I get a lot of
positive attention when I make the
football team I'm really feeling loved
when I make the cheerleading squad oo
when I got into that college or had that
major or made that money or bought that
nice car people really gave me a lot of
positive attention and we hiive
Achievers make a mistake of
fusing what we're doing with our
worthiness we start to believe that we
are only worthy of Celebration support
and love when we are doing
something that is worth celebrating or
worth validating or worth cheering for
and if you don't wake up and separate
the things that you're doing and
striving for for and the goals that you
have from your inherent selfworth as a
human
being you will forever feel this sense
that you're not enough you will forever
feel this void because if your selfworth
and your lovability Is Anchored In
achievement even when you make a million
dollars even when you make the New York
Times bestseller list even even when you
meet the person of your dreams the
second you achieve that thing you're
going to now look for something else
because your worth as a human being
depends on what you're doing the high
five habit is all about this radical
idea that will change your life and the
idea is
this if you are
breathing you're worthy of Celebration
the mere fact that you exist is why you
are worthy of being loved and supported
and forgiven and it's why you deserve
kindness it's not because you made it to
the gym it's not because you're making a
hundred grand it's not because you just
got promoted should you celebrate those
wins of course but those wins are not
the reason why you're an extraordinary
human being and you know I had this all
knotted up and you know I wondered why
why why did I you know ACH every time I
achieve my goals I would still see a
woman in the mirror that wasn't enough I
was my own worst critic and by critic
this is what I mean I was relentless in
focusing on what wasn't working I was
relentless in pointing out to myself all
the things I did wrong instead of the
thousand things I was doing right and
that constant grinding
Beatdown was so just much the default I
wasn't even aware of it until I
discovered the power of high-fiving
myself in the mirror and silencing that
critic and one of the reasons why it's
so important for you to be clear about
what you want out of this next chapter
in your life is because who you hang out
with it changes everything for you it
either keeps things the same or it will
be an accelerant that makes it easier
for you to make the changes in your life
that you really want to make and so this
is research from Harvard that I want you
to understand and it's what is grounding
the advice that I'm giving you today so
do you know that when researchers from
Harvard looked at people who had made a
major change in their lives in a
positive way okay so you take a group of
people that made a major change in their
life half of those people the reason why
that change happened is because
something either traumatic or something
that was a major life event happened
they got cancer they lost somebody they
loved they got a divorce they suddenly
were laid off they lost all their money
like something happened that was a major
life event that rocked them and you know
what happens when that happens to you
first it's horrendous but it usually
leads to something very very positive
happening now the other half of the
people who had made a very positive
change in their life do you want to know
what they did what they did is they
changed their friends they started
surrounding themselves with people that
were up to the same thing that they
wanted to be doing I'm sure you've
experienced this in your life have you
ever um gone to college and when you get
to college and suddenly you're around a
bunch of studious people it suddenly
makes you more studious have you ever
done a 5k or run a half marathon or done
a big walking uh fundraiser or done
tough mutter one of those big kind of
group events what's it like to be at a
race where people are cheering you on
where other people are running where
you're all doing the same thing it's
super motivating and there's even deeper
research around this because behavior is
contagious if you're around people that
smoke your objection to smoking gets
lowered because you get socialized to it
if you're around people that are super
positive your natural set in terms of
being pessimistic will slowly start to
raise if you're around people that every
morning they send a text I've got two
friends hi Jenny hi Sarah two of my uh
friends here that I text almost every
other day about what exercise class
we're going to just being around them
makes me more motivated and so James and
you I want you to really understand that
who you hang out out with matters it
matters not only because your time is
valuable and your attention is valuable
and your heart and soul is valuable but
it matters because the people that you
hang out with have an incredible impact
on you I believe that you are capable of
changing I do I've just seen too much
evidence over the course of my career
amazing changes that people just like
you and me have made so I know you're
thinking well this is great Mel but
where do I begin so step number one you
begin by making a wish just like that
moment on your birthday when you close
your eyes and wish for something to come
true in this next year of your life
right now do the same close your eyes
and think about the next year of your
life what do you want the next year of
your life to look like Begin by making a
wish that's how I began two years ago
yep my business was upside down kids
were in shambles my husband was
struggling with depression and I was
struggling with everything I had to
create a break from that moment of pain
and allow myself to see something
different at the time I had no idea what
the new chapter of my life would be or
could be here's what I did know I want
to stay in this one and that's all you
need to know all you need to know is you
don't want to stay in the place that
you're in right now that right there is
a wish for something better if you know
what you don't want it's very easy to
change as soon as you start removing or
letting go of things that aren't working
you'll see all new possibilities true
confidence Begins the moment you're
willing to try okay and so I I I really
think it's important I can give you
another example the first time somebody
handed me chopsticks I had no idea how
to use them was I nervous about picking
them up and I couldn't get like my
fingers to twist in the way that you're
supposed to and it was super embarrassed
and they kept like flipping across the
table and everybody here's the thing I
didn't know how to use
them but isn't it common sense that
there's no way I was going to learn how
to use them if I wasn't willing to try
see being confident and the skill of
confidence is the difference between
saying sure hand me the Chopsticks I'd
love to try I'm willing to look like an
idiot I'm willing to be a beginner first
versus going can you get me a fork I
don't know how to use those do you see
the difference the skill begins with
being willing to try so many of you saw
me on the Today's Show today that is the
culmination of 10 years of being willing
to try being willing to walk on a stage
and have a panic attack or a neck rash
being willing to get behind a microphone
and make terrible content or say stupid
things or look terrible in videos you
you know you got to remember what you're
seeing is a person on the Today Show who
has been working hard for 10 years
trying over and over and over and over
and learning and failing that's what
you're witnessing you're witnessing
competency but the skill is something
different the skill of confidence is
trying and you know let me remind you of
a fact everybody starts at zero everyone
whether you're trying to learn guitar
or you're building a social media
following or you want to get into the
YouTube space or you're writing a book
or you're selling a everybody starts at
zero that's how I started zero speeches
given zero television experience zero
social media following zero email
addresses zero competency in front of a
camera or on a microphone I mean even
take this podcast starting this I
started at zero the Tech is intimidating
there are 5 million podcasts on Spotify
alone I'm 54 years old I don't know how
to do that I haven't done this before I
haven't been in the seat of the person
that hosts but here's the difference
with your friend Mel Robbins I'm willing
to try I lean on this skill of
confidence that I've built because I
have the definition that's grounded in
research and so do you you're not going
to feel confident you're going to
act in accordance with the research of
confidence you my friend are willing to
try that's the secret the belief becomes
real when you start taking actions that
are aligned with the new
belief the new belief becomes real the
new belief becomes encoded in your brain
in your nervous system in your neural
Pathways in your habits in your systems
in the way you talk to yourself your new
belief becomes real when you take
actions that are aligned with the new
belief I did not make this up this is an
entire field of study called behavioral
activation therapy absolutely everything
that I teach you is grounded in
behavioral activation therapy I am
trying to make you
understand that before you feel like
like the person you want to become you
need to start acting like the person you
want to
become before you feel ready to go to
the gym for the first time in a year you
need to push yourself use the 5sec rule
take a 5-second moment of control 5 4 3
2 1 you need to push yourself to act
like a person now that is already got a
habit of going to the gym that's how
your belief that I deserve to be healthy
and I can figure out how to do it that's
how your belief goes from just a
statement that you say to a 5-second
moment of control 54321 take the action
and act like that person go to the gym
for those of you that want to write for
those of you that want to grow your
business ask yourself what is a person
that is a successful writer do every
single day they
write before you feel like a writer you
need to make yourself take actions that
a writer
takes so that as you stand and you start
to say I can figure out how to write a
book over time I could write a book but
then if you leave the bathroom after
saying that to yourself you now need to
push yourself to sit your ass in a chair
and do what a writer does which is write
about 500 pages of horse before you have
anything worthy of sharing with somebody
else if you struggle with growing your
business I guarantee you you're not
doing the work that would grow your
business you're thinking about all the
reasons why you can't we need to invert
this everybody you need to start saying
I am capable of figuring out how to grow
my business I am capable of pushing
through the fear and picking up the
phone and selling I am able to figure
this out and then you need to 54 3 21
take the actions before you're motivated
before you're ready before like when
you're afraid you can still take the
action when you're hesitating you can
still take action when you don't feel
ready you can still take the action
action is the only way you're going to
change your life and by the way action
is necessary you have to decide what you
want to believe and then you got to do
the really hard work to push yourself to
take the action before you're ready
that's the only way that you will change
how you think about yourself how you
think about your life how you think
about your future by deciding what you
want and pushing yourself to take action
5 Seconds at a time when you're scared
when you're anxious when you're not
feeling ready that's how you change
anything and that's how you put it all
together my husband and I have just uh
bought a house in Vermont and I know you
guys you know are in your new home it's
an incredible thing to do it is our
dream house it's the house that his
parents built it's the family house we
not only were able to purchase this
thing we've been able to completely
renovate it make it our own this place
is the closest place to God that I have
ever been we sit nestled between
mountains with 140 mile view straight
down a valley with cascading like it
is just spectacular when I would sit in
therapy sessions 8 years ago and my
therapist would ask me to come up with
like a um you know like a totem or a
spiritual guide or Vision whatever for
truth or God or what it's always this
View and so lo and behold eight years
later we freaking live there and I'm
sitting on this covered deck looking
down the valley my daughter is sitting
next to me other daughter who lives in
Boston who's 23 and it's
Sunday and normally on
Sundays I'm not even present on Sundays
because I'm now got the Sunday scaries
I'm now thinking about the week ahead
she is starting to now do that okay I
got to get going I got I got to pack the
car I got to get going I got I got a big
week of work this week and and it's 7:30
in the morning on a spectacular
day and the energy is starting and I
recognize the energy because that is the
campaign of misery that I have lived
with for 50 years and I'm sitting there
and I'm thinking oh this is
interesting that's
me and then I stopped in that moment Jay
and I thought I don't feel that right
now I just feel that exactly where I am
looking at this
view is
exactly where I'm supposed to be and it
was so profound it's almost like that
moment where eart tole has on the bench
in the beginning of the Power of Now
where I have this profound experience
where I think wait a minute is this
What happiness
is that I'm not 15 steps
ahead I'm just able to be right here
without the anxiety without the stress I
mean that is like a revolutionary
experience for me I don't think I had
ever not felt the default of a revved up
nervous system an anxious mind or a
to-do list that was a mile long and I
don't want to go back to that sort of
frenetic busyness that creates chronic
stress and you know the challenge for me
right now is how do I stay in a space
that's that's happy because I love the
game of building a business I love
pushing myself I love like and I
realized oh wait you actually need both
you need deep spiritual quiet time and
you need the busy of Los Angeles or
Boston or New York in small Sprints but
that can't be your fault anymore woman
there's somebody really close to us and
our family who has had this massive
uptick of anxiety happen and it has been
so debilitating that this person has
actually taken an entire week off of
work and I've been thinking that's
actually the opposite of what you should
do because if you are scared that you're
going to have a panic attack at work so
you don't go to work you're making the
anxiety bigger than you
avoiding that thing or avoiding the
situation that may happen makes the fear
bigger I've been in this boat too where
the anxiety's been so debilitating that
I I've actually had anxiety so bad that
it built and built and built and built
up inside me when I was a second-year
law student that I convinced myself that
there was no way that I could get on a
plane and go to Albuquerque New Mexico
where I had landed a summer job and be
able to live and work on my own and I
talk about avoidance I called that law
firm and told them that I had had a
family
emergency and I had to not come this was
two days before I was supposed to get on
the plane oh now and so I have done this
over and over and over and over again in
my life and I can't wait until you
unpack all the forms of avoidance but
you're right you do link
up this act of oh my gosh if I just
don't do it then I'm going to be okay
but you actually make it worse if you
want to
know how you are showing up and if you
want to truly
improve how you participate in that
relationship simply send your partner a
text that says how can I be a better
partner to
you and then ask for specifics and Chris
would tell me well you could flatten the
cardboard boxes you could throw out your
Kleenex you could put your phone down at
6:00 at
night you could um uh you could take the
dog for a walk in the morning you could
be more present you could like he he
would have a whole list of things that
would make a difference and most of us
don't bother to ask so that's number one
you're not not even asking and when you
ask that question your job is to listen
and elicit more things for you to do it
is not to defend yourself or to give
feedback there's something that you want
to
believe there's some change that you
want to make there's something that
you're called toward but you're just
scared and it's your old beliefs that
I'm going to regret this or this is
going to be a mistake or what if this
doesn't work out or what if this is the
worst thing I could have ever done or
what if that right and so this is where
I am and I want you to think about
what's some change that you want to make
in your
life and the belief that you need to
change in order to really lift yourself
up and support yourself through the
process of changing the belief that I
want to have is that this next chapter
is going to be the best chapter of my
life and that no matter what happens I'm
going to be okay that really it's not
about a house everybody it's about the
people that are in the house and now
that I'm here alone boy is that true but
I'm so scared to let go you know
everybody where you just know it's kind
of time to let go where it's let go of a
relationship or a place or a friendship
or a career that there's some big move
right and yeah I think I'm taking my
time with leaving a family home because
it is a big decision 24 years in one
place is a big thing having Roots
somewhere is a big thing and so my
belief and the belief that I want to
change is about
okayness it's about the permission to
take a risk and to dream and to trust
myself because you know when I close my
eyes just like when you close your eyes
and think about about this change that
you want to make you know what's right
for
you yes fa says it feels like a part of
you will die if you leave the truth is a
part of me does need to die because I'm
no longer in that chapter of my life and
I'm holding on to it right you say the
key to successful days really starts
every single morning what's your routine
yeah what do you do well I want
everybody to think about this like a
domino mhm so what is the first decision
that you make in the morning because
that one decision will actually trigger
either negative decisions or positive
decision so decision number one get your
rear end out of bed don't push snooze
absolutely not there's a lot of brain
science around it uh you actually if you
fall back asleep you put yourself in a
state of sleep inertia which makes you
uh for the next four hours it makes your
brain groggy and it makes it yeah yeah
so get up when you get up get up 54321
get out of that bed and make your bed
I'm not trying to turn you into a Navy
SEAL I'm just saying complete one thing
yeah so the third thing that you're
going to do is I want you to go into the
bathroom and I want you to look in the
mirror and then I want you to say
nothing and I want you to highfive the
human being you see in the mirror in the
morning every single morning after you
brush your teeth you do this every
morning let's a quick
look right after I brush my teeth look
in the
mirror really look in the mirror and
then oh God I love doing that I love
sending myself into the day with a high
five I got my own back let's go let me
tell you the science tell us so for your
entire life you guys you have given
other people a high five right yeah when
you give somebody else a high five what
does it mean you're doing great a girl a
girl and what do you and you've never
gone oh I hate you there you go ever and
so the programming is already in your
basal ganglia it's already a habit to
associate this with I love you go get
them you got this I see you when you do
it to yourself something crazy happens
you aim all of that lifetime of positive
neurological programming right back at
yourself something else you said which I
love is a lot of people have their phone
next to their bed and we always hear
don't put it don't put it but your
reasoning behind why you don't put it
like why it that isn't the first thing
you see let me demonstrate okay most of
us either have it here right or we have
it like this right so what happens is
you wake up it's your alarm yeah you
immediately do this right so the first
thing that you are putting into your
brain talk about not making space for
yourself you have just set the entire
world into your mind you have let work
stress you out you have looked at social
media and everybody else's life and now
you think you're behind in some fake
race and so here's the thing you can't
trust yourself I can't trust myself and
so what do you do you leave it in the
other room it is literally in the
bathroom in the bathroom and I leave the
ringer on we have a senior in college in
Los Angeles I need
you want to know something crazy The
Today Show will text you all night long
they'll only call you if it's an
emergency an emergency correct so you'll
hear the call but it's not there so when
you wake up tomorrow morning and you
literally go like this and then the
alarm rings and you're kind of screwed
over because now you got to get out of
bed to turn the thing off and you're
going to be like I hate that M Robin's
person but by the time you get to the
bathroom guess what you don't care to to
be obsessed you have a chance to turn it
off and take the space for yourself yes
and you've already gotten up there's no
snooze you got up yes okay I hate it I
hate it I hate this habit now you're in
it now you're in it the study suggests
that when you use an alter
ego or you create a vision of the future
you the person you want to become it
gives you distance from the scaredy cat
you who's never done this thing before
so ask yourself you know who I what I
always ask myself I go well what would
the rock do in this situation I just
love Dwayne Johnson The Rock I
constantly use him as my avatar when it
comes to confidence what would the rock
do in this moment and I always get an
answer and it feels less personal
because you and I are friends you can
use the rock you can use me what would
Mel do if you're feeling unsure and you
want to tap into the confidence that you
kind of pick up on for me and this also
Taps into a entire body of research that
I talk about a lot on the Mel Robins
podcast which is behavioral activation
therapy Decades of research show that
when you start acting like the person
you want to become in the future now in
your present life it's one of the
fastest ways for you to change your
mindset for you to create new habits why
because when you start acting like the
person you want to become in the future
you start acting like that person today
what are you doing you're trying you're
trying to act like the future you would
act none of what you're doing is a
choice you are stuck in Old patterns
based on your childhood you're scared to
death of people leaving
you and your feelings and your fears are
making you so hesitant and the other
reason why this is not a choice is you
deeply believe you're not worthy of
love and so you don't know how to act as
though you deserve
it and so if you want to quote be me use
me as an avatar and when you start to
get those feelings coming up in your
body like I can't do this just be like
what the would Mel
say because here's I'm not right or
wrong and this is your life Brooke so
you got to decide what's right for you
but I will tell you if you stay stay in
that feeling emotional space of I can't
do this I don't know what to
say you're just going to continue to
have the same
thing but if you want
something different you got to show up
and act in a different way my personal
experience is that I think it took me
decades to heal because I became so good
at talking about my anxiety and
intellectualizing my anxiety and talking
about what happened to me and how it
made me feel and all of that was helpful
so that I was aware of what happened I
was aware of what I was feeling and I
also from that level was able to come up
with ways to cope whether that was yoga
or taking anxiety medication or it was
getting into therapy but I wasn't doing
the work to truly heal the root cause of
the anxiety and it wasn't until I
stopped talking about it and I got below
the
neck and started dealing with the
uncomfortable feelings and the stored
memories in my nervous system which is
very different than talking about how
you feel mhm getting into your body and
feeling that kink in the nervous system
that memory that you wish that you could
forget that is when I
truly flipped the pancakes so to speak
and started to change for real one act
of kindness from one
person can change somebody's entire life
and you have that power and so I want
you to think as you head into your day
about the image of blowing bubbles you
know when a kid is blowing bubbles and
the bubbles catch the sunlight and they
float around and they fly away it feels
so good doesn't it it makes you smile
and you can stand there on a beautiful
sunny day and blow bubbles and they
drift off into space and who knows how
far they go your energy is just like
that and you can spread good energy and
you should how do you do that be
generous with the I love yous be super
generous telling people I appreciate you
in fact I have a habit every single day
I make it a habit to tell somebody that
I appreciate them and I do that by
either reaching out to a friend and
telling them that I miss them and I'm
thinking about them I have a friend
who's going through uh a really
challenging moment right now with her
dad hospice has been called in and I'm
texting her every morning telling her
that I'm sending her a hug and that she
doesn't need to text me back but I just
want her to know that I'm here for her I
tell that to people that help me in the
grocery store I tell it to anybody
honestly because we all need to hear it
thank you for helping me thank thank you
for being here I love complimenting
people's nails or their jewelry or their
hairstyle or their socks and smiling
smiling and don't forget your
family when somebody walks in the door
how do you greet
them do you put a big smile on your face
do you run to the door do you say
welcome home oh my God I hope you had a
great day I always always always give
our son Oakley the biggest hug and I
hold it extra TI and I tell him I'm so
happy to see him because every time you
do this you smile you wave you highfive
somebody you give them a hug you tell
them that you love them you text
somebody out of the blue you are a Force
for good if you're staying in a hotel
like I'm going to be tonight leave a
note for the person that's cleaning your
room a thank you a smiley face tell them
you appreciate him we all need to hear
it and when you become radically
generous with your positive energy with
your compliments with your enthusiasm
with your love it spreads
unbelievable waves of joy and positivity
lifting people up in ways that you'll
never know why is it so hard to break
through some daily habits and do things
differently why can't I stay consistent
in my daily tasks I'll tell you why
you're frustrated the same reason why
every any organizer is frustrated
because you trying to stay consistent in
your head and you are not using simple
systems and simple physical cues to keep
you organized and to keep these changes
top of mind that's it and you are you
are managing so much and you listening
to me you don't give yourself enough
credit for how much you juggling in your
own mind stop keeping Behavior change in
your own mind and let's get it out of
your head because I want you to know
something you're not the problem
you have everything within you you're
not the problem you are capable of
learning new habits you are capable of
making amazing things happen you're not
the problem the problem is that you're
attacking this as an any organizer you
are planning to do this all in your head
and all you need is Audi systems that
keep these new changes front and center
in front of you that's how you stay
consistent
stop relying on Willpower stop relying
on having to remember what you need to
do absolutely not there is no way you
are going to achieve your goals or stay
consistent or make all those amazing
changes that you want to make that you
deserve to have happen unless you start
to implement systems in your life just
to give you a visual everybody you know
tomatoes and high summer August at a
farmer market bright deep opaque shine
tiny red that was basically the color of
my face my hair is starting to grow out
so the roots are coming in nice and gray
and uh I put on my glasses and they
fogged up for all I know I had a camel
toe and I was walking down uh the
sidewalk in La outside of the yoga
studio headed to my favorite coffee shop
to basically get a cup of liquid
caffeinated sugar and I pulled out that
phone cuz I thought you know what I did
not want to go this morning my sinuses
are bothering me me I know you can
relate to that and so I just start
filming and I agree I looked like
absolute but here's what I
think I walk around looking like that so
why would I be worried about putting it
online like if you walk into the grocery
store wearing a pair of yoga tights and
your bra is showing through your T-shirt
and you're sweaty and your hair is a
mess why do you feel bad putting a photo
of yourself looking like that online
like you got to stop and consider that
you're okay going out in public or being
around friends looking like crap because
that's how we all look in real life but
somehow that's not acceptable on social
media and so it's been very liberating
for me to just go it I don't care what I
look like cuz I walk into a grocery
store looking like this I know I look
like who cares but the public and what I
look like in public is exactly what I'm
willing and I think you should put on
social media because if you don't you're
subconsciously giving a about your
appearance and I think that's really as
you guys keep like teing up these
examples of where I'm either completely
violating social norms like the no toes
policy which I was unaware of or I am
being really offensive by taking my
shirt off and doing what I thought was a
very polite discreet move of covering my
nipples with my t-shirt so I could get
some sun because I feel depressed and
translucent like a gray dolphin living
here in southern Vermont but I think the
real liberating thing about learning how
to give a sh is that you put your energy
toward giving a towards things that
matter and you spend less time draining
your energy on the that really doesn't
matter and one of the things that I gave
up a long time ago Christine is worrying
about what I look like and maybe it was
because of the experience of being a
commentator on CNN because when I was on
CNN I was on CNN as you know Christine
as an on-air commentator a paid legal
commentator there were only five of us
in the entire world that were on that
team and it was a really cool job
analyzing some of the biggest cases um
of our
time uh I noticed something that
whenever I would be on TV and I would
have an opinion about particularly a
case that people were really hot about
like um Trayvon Martin's murder or what
happened in Ferguson or Freddy gray or
Tamir rice and I'm a criminal defense
attorney and so I am adding in
commentary as a defense attorney I notic
that when people criticized me they
never criticize what I
said people on Twitter or on social
media here I am on television talking
about this very serious topic I take the
job very seriously they're like you old
bag you you know have you seen your neck
you know like just dragging my down my
jowls that look like saddle bags or my
saggy ass turkey gizzard neck or just
constantly trashing me that I just
learned how to tune it out and I started
to not care and there's something very
liberating about leaving an exercise
class and your mascara from last night
is running down your face like Dracula
and going and getting your coffee anyway
you know why cuz you don't give a what
the other people who are standing in
line around you think about the fact
that you're mascara is running and half
of them you're probably never going to
see again anyway so who gives a if you
struggle with being kind to
yourself it is never too early or too
late to have an enormous breakthrough in
your relationship to yourself and this
is really important it's really
important because based on the research
there was this massive study done in the
UK where they took a look at absolutely
every single Behavior or attitude change
you could make or you could practice in
terms of improving your life and they
looked at everything they looked at
changing your diet practicing gratitude
having a meditation practice exercising
regularly seeing your friends more all
the things that we know we should be
doing right but do you know that the
single Behavior change that has the
biggest and most profound impact on your
quality of your day-to-day life is
simply being kinder to
yourself yeah that's right according to
the research being kinder to yourself
learning how to accept and love yourself
it is the biggest mover in terms of your
happiness meaning confidence all of it
and the sad thing about this study is
that habit of being kinder to yourself
of accepting yourself of loving yourself
it's the one we practice the least every
single day make it a habit to text a
friend
friend just out of the
blue and if you want to amplify this
take a selfie video hey I'm just on my
walk and I was thinking of you and hey
my dog says hello and you not only
underestimate how much people like you
you underestimate how much it means to
somebody when they hear from
you this isn't just me this is research
that was covered in the New York Times
recently about how receiving an
unexpected text from a
friend makes you immediately feel
connected to that person and it makes
the Friendship stronger make it a
practice every single day as you start
your day to reach out to one friend with
a random message I want to tell you I
love you I believe in you and I believe
in your ability to stop telling yourself
these lies and to really embrace the
truth
the truth is you deserve amazing
friendships you need amazing friendships
and you are that amazing friend that
somebody who is going through a very
lonely season digging their way to a new
life needs desperately right now in
terms of my own experience with getting
serious about creating the skill of
confidence is it's a GameChanger the
more that you build confidence in your
life the greater the risks going to take
and that's critical in business in life
for fulfillment I also have the ability
to say no and not even be bothered by
what other people are going to feel why
because I have the skill of confidence
it also makes you an incredible
negotiator because you realize you would
rather be respected than be liked and
see this kind of need to be liked or to
look good is part of the reason why you
doubt yourself all the time I want you
to bring that power back internally
that's what the skill of confidence does
and you'll also be able to recognize
when you're afraid of something and that
that fear is just kind of [__] in
your head and you have a choice you
don't have to let fear stop you anymore
and that's where the skill of confidence
comes in and the same's going to be true
for you first we're going to talk about
globally how I want you to think about
being able to focus your
attention and get things done okay and
this is on a daytoday basis first of all
when I talk about productivity and the
ability to focus your attention on a
day-to-day basis I want you to
understand a simple fact in order to get
things done in order to direct your
focus and move through a task you are
going to require some brain power and so
I want you to think about your brain
like a a car engine right and a car
engine is what you need in a car to
power you forward and your brain is like
an engine that will power you forward to
help you get tasks done now an engine
requires fuel right and sure enough your
brain has a certain amount of fuel so
imagine that you got like a tank that
has fuel in it in your brain okay and as
you wake up and as you go through your
day and as you direct your attention on
things guess what happens to that fuel
in your brain it starts to drain and so
I want you to know this because the
tactics and the tools that I'm about to
teach you relate to the fuel in your
brain and what times of day you have the
most fuel what times of day you are more
likely to be be able to focus okay and
what do you think everybody is the best
time of day for your brain and for the
amount of fuel that you have in your
brain naturally in order to be able to
tap into it and drive your focus at
something that's important to you I love
this you guys are right Laura says my
brain is mush by the end of the day
everybody's saying morning morning
morning I see somebody saying I feel
like I'm on empty this is a really good
analogy because there are times where
you feel like your brain is full of gas
and you're able to direct your attention
and focus and then there are times where
you're like Jesus I feel like I'm
running on empty I'm running on fumes
here and you're absolutely right
everybody it is mornings when you wake
up generally what the research shows is
that your brain is primed to be able to
focus for the first 4 hours of the day
the first four hours of the day tend to
be for most of us the time of day when
your brain has the most fuel and when
your speed of processing is awesome and
when you are able to direct your
attention at what you need to be focused
on okay so now there's a caveat to this
you can manufacture boosts of
productivity and boosts of feeling like
you've got a little bit more brain power
number one immediately after you
exercise so if you have a burst of
cardio 30 minutes is what a lot of the
research says but if you have a burst of
cardio you will get a little bit of
increase in fuel another thing that
helps is getting outside getting outside
uh when you start to feel your energy
and your focus start to go to empty
getting outside is another way to give
yourself a boost of brain power I want
to become empowered to improve my work
situation so I want to ask you about
unhealthy work environments and the side
effects they manifest where should I
start making changes well one thing I
want to acknowledge really quickly is
that you do have the power to change
this because positive energy is also
very contagious and if you protect your
energy you can take proactive steps to
call people out on their behavior and so
that's what we're going to talk about
now and I want to bring a study into
this because there was a new study by
the workforce Institute at ukg that
found that 69% of people say that their
managers have the greatest impact on
their mental
health that their managers had the same
level of impact on their mental health
as their partner or spouse at home now
this was more than the impact that their
doctor or therapist had on their mental
health and this was a huge study they
looked at 3,400 people across 10
countries and so you are right negative
people at work particularly a manager
really bad for your mental health
because you can't fix them and for me
there are two types of jerks out there
and we've already started to kind of
unpack this but I really want to
highlight this for you there are the
jerks that are just entitled like I
believe the woman at the hotel front
desk was that she just thinks she's
better than everybody else and they
treat people like crap because they've
always treated people like crap you know
people like this they're rude to waiters
they're short with other people they're
full of themselves they have a tone to
their voice they're super pompous we
hate these kind of people the kind of
people that are rude for no reason other
than because this is how they are and
this is how they treat people and I hate
people like this and you know what else
I can't stand I can't stand the fact
that they tend to bully us right and we
just give in and it just perpetuates
this people get a better room because
they're mean to the person at the front
desk the world should not work like this
but it drains our energy that's why we
give in and so there's that type of jerk
and then there's the second type which
is more like the person in that coffee
shop that I was explaining where they're
just under pressure and they can't
tolerate the discomfort that they feel I
call these kind of people emotionally
immature and I use the word immature
because they throw Tantrums they're like
a child who is so frustrated so they
throw themselves on the floor and
they're immature because they do not
have a mature or
responsible way of tolerating emotional
stress and so in these situations at
work you have a couple choices number
one we've already talked about the snow
globe this one works like a charm
because it gives you objectivity allows
you to visualize the
Tantrum and it makes you feel a little
bit better than the person honestly and
so that's one thing a second thing that
you can do is you are allowed to call
people out on this
behavior in the first question that we
got you heard the example of somebody
getting a really rude email there's
nothing wrong with picking up the phone
or walking down the hall and saying hey
is something going on with you because I
don't know if you know how the tone of
this email comes across but it doesn't
feel good and most people when you call
them out on that and you kind of start
off with hey is something going on with
you because this isn't like you and the
tone is really
demeaning and is there something you
want to tell me or are you una aware
that this is like how you're speaking to
people that is the way that you can call
somebody out and obviously if you have
somebody that is engaging in this
consistently document it go to HR
because you shouldn't be under a barrage
of that kind of abusive language or
demeaning language or that sort of like
really unnecessary pressure that's not
why you're in your job and so you can go
to HR but you know you can walk down the
hall you can pick up the phone and you
can say I'm more than happy to help you
with these things but only if you speak
to me in a respectful Manner and this is
not respectful and I'm sorry you're
having a bad day but don't take it out
on me my son actually used to say that
to me and so did my kids they would
literally go I don't know what's going
on at work but don't take it out on me I
don't work with you and so call the
person out and if you're not comfortable
start documenting it and then go to HR
and try to um get some help with it one
of the best places to start is by adding
a simple Habit to your morning routine
or your evening routine which is to
write down five things that you want
they can be small they can be big
anything so let me see if I can get the
three steps to developing synchronicity
as a superpower in your life number one
you have to supercharge your attention
about what you want and if you don't
know what you want start writing five
dreams down every damn day and if you
want help with that go to melrobbins.com
dream big we've got a sheet that
thousands of you have already downloaded
that'll walk you through how to do this
make this a practice because this all
begins with what's inside your mind
inside your heart and so you got to get
serious about putting your attention on
what you want instead of bitching about
the things that you don't have or the
way that things are so superpower your
attention is Step number one for
developing synchronicity in your life
correct yep yep okay great so step
number two Professor Myers if I'm
getting this is opening up your heart to
those moments where now that you have
supercharged your attention and said I
want that damn Gucci handbag I don't
care that it's sold out I don't care
that this or I want friends I need more
friends in my life I'm lonely so you
supercharge your attention to what you
want and then you got to be
open to the in the beginning
coincidences that you could easily be
like that's the way that my phone
listens to me and it's serving up ads or
oh that person's just reaching out cuz
they want something you got to get rid
of your negative filter on what's
happening around you and you got to wake
the hell up and realize that all around
you Dr Meyers is here to profess people
he has researched this all around you
are magical connections and it's
connected to what you want inside you
yeah and the second and and the emotion
that comes with that you you you feel
you feel it yes and so you got to start
to get positive and intentional about
calling out these signs that life is
trying to help you that things are going
in the right direction you got to grab
one little thing and use it as like a
little toe hold to hold on to and then
when you call out that sign you got to
walk toward it yeah yeah is that right
yeah you know I never realized that this
is how I live my
life like I think what I've learned in
this conversation is that
synchronicity is something that I've
been tapping into for a very long time
and there were periods in my life where
I wasn't tapping into it and I was
completely out of alignment and it was
full of friction and self-destruction
and then there have been periods where
I've allowed myself to say what I want
or at least say what wasn't
working and I allowed myself to start to
believe in the signs that would be
presented and having done a tremendous
amount of research about the reticular
activity system and the filter in our
brains and how you can change your mind
and how your mind can help you I really
hope that as you're listening to this
conversation yes you I'm talking to you
that you will open your heart and your
mind to this because it's very real I
mean they wouldn't be given the Nobel
Prize to somebody doing quantum
entanglement if two particles a Lighty
your away could not like impact one
another and I want you to realize the
power of your thoughts and you to
realize that the world is trying to help
you that you are meant to live in
alignment that synchronicity is not only
possible it's something that you're
wired to do and you can start today
Deborah says what about complaining
about things that genuinely take time to
resolve like I'm getting over being
sick let me ask you a question
does complaining about being
sick actually help you get
better it's a fair
question you're allowed to complain if
it's productive if it makes you feel
better to
go and saying it is helpful
terrific if doing that makes you feel
even
worse try not to do
it say things like boy I'm on day three
of this I must be getting
better boy uh the meds are going to kick
in at any
moment you know when it starts Chris is
looking at me like what are you talking
about no it's just somebody mentioned do
thoughts count you know there outbound
sort of out outward complaining but then
there's complaining in your own mind of
course thoughts count because you know
what you complain about the most
yourself your body
your
intelligence what you just said the fact
that you didn't go to the gym the fact
that you didn't uh do what you said you
were going to do the beating yourself up
is a form of complaining because you're
expressing
dissatisfaction for
yourself and the problem with all this
is that when you do it habitually or
when you complain as just a default mode
and you don't realize how much you're
doing it you're allowing your mind to
filter the world a certain way and
you're allowing yourself to live in
existence where your own thoughts are
poisonous if you feel like hell and you
got the flu and you've just thrown up in
the toilet complain all you want vent
all you want you just earned that but at
some point you're going to have to stop
feeding the monster and putting poison
in your own mind and you're going to
have to teach yourself how to start to
find Milestones that are positive so
that you can become healthier so that
you can change how you think not
everybody is meant to be your friend and
the second that it feels like a force be
flexible okay here's one of the things
that I love to think about is that you
can be the whole package but if you're
delivered to the wrong address not going
to work another quote that I've seen
that I just love is you could be the
most amazing juicy end of summer ripe
Peach but if you don't like peaches
you're not going to be a fit for that
person doesn't matter how good you are
remember
flexibility I want you to understand
this because when you tell yourself oh I
got to be liked by everybody everybody's
got to like me I got to be everybody's
friend that lie turns you into people
pleaser that lie is why you are in your
head going do they like me how do I need
to change I know I'm a peach and they
don't like peaches but maybe if I
disguise myself as a plum the LA like me
stop doing that embrace the fact that
you're a peach embrace your whole
package and stop forcing yourself to be
liked by everybody the reason why this
lie is so important to catch is because
there's nothing wrong with you the more
you Embrace who you are the more you
honest about what works for you the more
you show up as your full self imagine
that imagine assuming that people just
like you that juicy Peach that you are
as you
are imagine if you just assume imagine
if you're flexible imagine who might
show up somebody who likes peaches
wouldn't that be a wonderful change
that's why you got to catch that because
this is about energy this is about you
and where you are in your life and where
you're going matching with beautiful
human beings that are on that same leg
of the journey with you that's what this
is about so be flexible and man you are
juicy Peach Embrace that
stuff motivation is
garbage yep Mel
Robbins one of the most successful
motivational speakers in the world just
said motivation is
garbage you see you're making the same
mistake we all make when we think about
motivation you're waiting to feel
motivated first before you take action
and you've been told a lie about
motivation see you've been made to
believe that you got to feel motivated
that that feeling that emotion is going
to come before the action it's actually
the opposite you got to take action and
the motivation comes and that's why the
first
takeaway is motivation is garbage
because my definition of motivation is
is that it's just a feeling and it comes
and it goes okay that's the way that
you've been using it and the irony is
you need motivation motivation is
fundamental you need this desire to move
in order to finish a project you got to
have motivation to get out of bed to
move off the couch to head to that
networking meeting and I know that you
felt motivated before you felt motivated
when you're on a team and uh lots of
people are yelling at you you felt
motivated when uh you need to pay your
bills but the truth is when you're alone
and you got something that you need to
do that's hard or that's I don't know
going to require some effort or that
scares you a little bit or it's going to
put you out there guess what's not going
to be there motivation you're going to
come up with every excuse in the book
why you shouldn't make your calls why
you shouldn't go to the gym why you
don't feel like going out of bed and
that's because if you rely on the
feeling of motivation first you're
waiting for something that's never going
to come that's why you've spent years
thinking about what you need to do
instead of just doing what you need to
do waiting for motivation is a trap
because you're never going to feel like
doing the things you need to do to
create a better life period one of the
things that I notice can happen when you
are in a period in your life where
you're trying to heal you're investing
in yourself in your personal growth you
mention that you're working on trauma
you're trying to dig out of some of the
holes maybe that you feel like you fell
into you're trying to change your
mindset that's serious work that was me
for years too here's the problem with
having a big healing Journey you're not
having any fun I think about periods of
my life when I was going through a lot
of change and I was working on myself
and I was doing everything that you're
doing every book I picked up was
self-help everything that I listened to
was self-improvement I couldn't even
remember the last time I read a fiction
novel or I went to a concert or I went
to a party everything got so serious
because my focus became so serious and
my focus was about improving my life
improving my life improving my life and
doing the work to change your life it's
important doing the work to identify
toxic patterns that you have or bad
thinking patterns that make you feel
like that's super important but you must
also double down on the fun while you're
doing the deeper work and so the first
thing that I want you to do is I want
you to set an intention that your number
one goal this year is to have more fun
to invest in that first category hedonic
happy
that researchers say is so important
because yes it's meaningful yes it's
fulfilling to do the hard work to change
your life for the better but changing
your life for the better also means that
you need more moments of fun in your
life how you create a better life with
goal setting because goal setting from
this point forward must be a part of
your life if you want to feel a greater
sense of purpose and meaning period and
so I want you to come back to this
episode I want you to bookmark it I want
you to share this with people that you
care about if you've got somebody like I
do who's a college senior and as they
approach graduation and they start to
feel like they're about to have a
quarter life crisis and they're lost you
know what they need they need goals if
you have a friend going through divorce
you know what they need they need goals
if you're bored in Life or feeling stuck
or you got to hit the reinvention button
you know what you need you need goals
and you can relisten to this every
single quarter at any moment in your
life and walk yourself through this very
simple but powerful and life-changing
research to get very clear about what
you want and why you want it and how
you're going to go achieve it now
speaking about the how you want to know
how habits are how you achieve goals
systems are how you make it easier and
the other thing you have to to
understand is that there are going to be
legs of your journey in life and this is
one of the hardest things where people
are going to pull off and take a
different route that's okay they may
come back at another time that's okay
and you know the final thing that I
wanted to say about this is it's a very
simple exercise that you can do with
somebody and this helps somebody who is
either struggling with happiness and
doesn't know how to get started or is
struggling with
confidence and is not able to take
action or who is resisting the changes
that you are doing and you would love to
see them
do we did this with our daughter who uh
is now 23 and last summer when she
graduated from college really unhappy I
mean two years of college had been
imploded and she was extremely depressed
and basically just drank her way through
it and graduated and was not happy big
life change nothing was going according
to plan she had planned this huge trip
to go to Cambodia and do a big service
trip for four months that wasn't going
to happen just
lost and so Chris and I sat with her for
a couple hours and then I said and she's
like I don't know what to do I'm 22 I'm
stuck I'm miserable I don't even know
how to start and I Saidi actually think
you do I think you're just scared take
out a blank piece of paper draw a line
down the center on the left hand side I
want you to write happy me now close
your
eyes and think about a time that you
remember being happy or more confident
or Alive it could be any word you want
right and you might have to go back to
Childhood our daughter closed her eyes
and she said it was senior year in high
school and I said okay so write down all
of the things that you were doing in a
week of your life senior year in high
school just describe your life for me oh
I got up at and and do it in detail
everybody I got up at 7:00 a.m. or 6:30
I was leaving the house by 7:00 I was
with my friends all day I was looking
forward to go to college I was playing
varsity lacrosse I was exercising 6 days
a week I was only partying with friends
twice a week I you know was in a healthy
dating relationship I ate four dinners a
night at home like
just great write down what your life
looks like now I sleep till 1 I drink
every day I feel like I don't see my
friends because everybody's scattered
now that we graduate I don't have
anything to look forward to my my trip
to Cambodia is canceled I'm not
exercising okay compare the
two your own life experience offers the
map and we want to over complicate these
big words like happiness I know I did
for decades or
confidence it's
actually found in the little
things if you do this simple exercise of
drawing a line down a piece of paper and
you write down what life looked like in
great detail when did you wake up when
did you go to bed how are we with
friends family what were you doing for
work exercise what were you
eating if you then compare that to what
life looks like now you now know what to
do and the fact is your whole life is
the little things it's when you wake up
it's the first thing you look at it's
what you do with your body it's how you
greet your spouse it's how you talk to
yourself it's what you say to yourself
when you look in the mirror it's the
mood that you walk in to work with
intentionally it's how you greet your
animals or your roommate when you end
the day it's the tone of voice that you
use that's your whole
life and if you were to just take the
time and intentionally write down a few
simple things that you do when you're
happy in life and you were to focus for
the next seven days on just adding one
of those in a day you would be very
surprised how getting some of the little
things right actually starts to turn
your life in a completely different
direction the 5-second rule leverages
proven principles in modern psychology
and there are literally hundreds of
examples that I could point to first
let's talk about two concepts one called
locus of control the second called a
bias toward action so a locus of control
is a foundational principle in
Psychology you should Google it back in
the day researchers figured out that
there are basically two kinds of people
people that believe that they're in
control of their lives and folks that
believe that life is just happening to
them and they're a victim of whatever
might happen now when you look at these
two types of people people that have an
internal locus of control a belief that
they're in control of their lives
they're happier they're more successful
more productive so the question becomes
how do you create an internal locus of
control in yourself the answer is simple
it's called a bias toward action so a
bias toward action is a psychological
principle that means you're the kind of
person that has a bias toward taking
action instead of a bias toward thinking
how do you create a bias toward action
you guessed it the 5-second rule the
5-second rule is a tool that will teach
you how to take action and over time as
you use it you not only learn how to
take action you become the kind of
person that operates with a bias toward
taking action and when you take action
over and over and over on your instincts
on your desires on your commitments
guess what you get you build an internal
locus of control you become the kind of
person that believes that you're in
control of your life because you're
proving it to yourself one 5-second
decision at a time once you make that
first cold
call you're likely to keep going once
you start writing that first sentence on
this chapter you're going to keep
writing once you hit record on that
video on the video you're going to keep
going once you fill out the first name
last name line on the application you
need to fill out you're going to keep
going once you pull up your resumé
template and you start
writing you're going to keep going
because the problem isn't your ability
to do what you need to do the problem is
you've been trapped in this stress and
Trauma and nervous system triggered
vicious procrastination cycle and look I
know this sounds like
really oh my God Mel come on I I I I was
listening to this because I want to be
more productive I want to make more
money I want to get more [__] done I
want to have more life balance now
you're telling me productivity it's
about forgiving myself it's about
calling forth the future
me why would I want to try that I told
you procrastination was not about
productivity and I also told you that
the thing that triggers it was going to
surprise you you and that's why this
topic is so
important I say every day that it is
never too late to wake up and be the
person you want to be and you deserve
that and here's the truth on how you do
that you have to act like you believe in
yourself before you believe in
yourself I'm going to say that again you
want to learn how to stop doubting
yourself you want to learn how to
believe in yourself again you want to
learn how to not be so afraid or full of
Doubt or full of perfectionism which by
the way is something you learned in
order to cope with crap that was going
on in childhood perfectionism everybody
is what you do in order to protect
yourself from rejection there's a huge
huge connection between your desire to
be perfect procrastinating and the fear
of rejection and so using these tools
you not only are going to break the
pattern of
procrastination you have a road map for
the actions that take you to the Future
you because again you have to act like
you believe in yourself before you do
believe in yourself so let me just make
this super super detailed for you vidy
when you wake up tomorrow morning and
you sit down in that chair and you walk
through these simple steps that I have
just taught you based on the
research when you start
drawing you are acting like you believe
in
yourself and notice you started drawing
before you did believe in
yourself that's why this is so
powerful when you see yourself
acknowledging that you're
procrastinating and labeling the stress
and forgiving yourself for getting
triggered by it and then 5 43
21 doing it anyway because you're the
kind of person that picks up the phone
or picks up the pen or walks out the
door or says that thing or does that
thing and you keep doing that
consistently you know what's going to
happen you're not only going to get the
results that you want you're going to
believe in yourself because you're going
to see yourself doing the work to get
the results that you want it begins with
the action because you made it this far
in a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hasht believe down in the comments Below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
for some incredible Marie forio
motivation check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there in the beginning when I was first
growing the business and first getting
it off the ground I was definitely um
work life balance was less of a reality
because I just had to work constantly in
order to keep the lights on